thank you Mr chair I would like to move
um interim study on hb1
1657 we have a motion made by second
byes
st7
discuss yes I'll just speak briefly um
the bill uh certainly has an adoral
intent in that it seeks to uh further
protect students from the unreasonable
predations of hazing behavior on college
campuses however as drafted there are
considerable issues with interpretation
and the language some of the language
appears to be so broad that behavior
such as cramming for a test late into
the night or uh being subjected to
participating outdoor activity in the
rain or even just simply being a pledge
being excluded from an
organization uh could theoretically
constitute hazing Behavior under this
bill um we like the intent we'd like to
continue to look at this bill and to see
if we can work on it to see if we can
narrow these things a bit further so
it's not so broad thank
you thank you Mr chair I absolutely
agree with representative beler
is there any further discussion and I
just advise to Comm there's going to be
a number of bills today which we're not
going to agree on and so we know that
and we're just going to have emotions
made no discussion get them off our
plate we'll end up where we know we're
going no sense wasting time so at this
point in time we have concurring
recommendation here so let's act on M
Madam clerk call the role please Vice
chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
peternell my will turn on but yes okay I
heard that representative Corell yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna not here okay uh
representative Heath yes representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 19 y one absent consent
everybody consent thank
you for me 190 19 in room study
consent okay um I'm looking down through
these early bills there another
one
we're going to bounce back up on our
listing here we're going to look at HB
1206 I know it should be 126 numerical
order it take moment yeah yeah we all
are jumping like
that a sure
represent Miler you recognize for a
motion I I recommend
I and
I I have an amendment coming to 1206 we
were gonna wait
yeah I thought that was
1397 no
oh 1397 yes I will have to amend but
we're going to get together this is 1206
is the one I just requested the
amendment and it takes out the part that
most people
objected
just well here we are and you said it
wasn't an early Bill and that was
fun the reason why we jump to other
bills right now is the early bills we
need to have everybody present and we
have one person out testifying in
another location right now so we're not
taking up any early bills till we have a
full deck well that's fine but this has
an amendment suppos to
be well take that an entire you want to
withraw your motion so we can move on oh
sure okay the motion is
withdrawn okay
um are you good with the
Frameworks yeah per framework 1161 no
11:07 that's the that's the one we
talked about this morning
yeah par me we we're trying to decide
which one we're going
in that's
okay
only because sing around we're doing the
order
sheet
did you want to go back well back so do
you want to go back to the ear okay we
have everybody back we're going to jump
to the early bills we got everybody
here okay the next bill down par
me right
we we just
did uh
um yeah we are in
1670 the out
of I got
it
more time me to get my
pag one two testing one
two do you want to test
yours no it's working it's
on okay check one two okay I think we're
ready to go the bill which we're looking
at 16 70 relative to including all
special education costs under State
education grants represent you recognize
for a motion I make a motion of itl is
there a
second second okay we have a motion made
by represent Dr itl and 1670 second by
represent beler represent dve would you
like to speak to your motion yes just
briefly um on this coming Friday the
subcommittee is going to talk about two
bills one that deals with special
education one that deals with swept this
bill 1670 deals with both of those we
have another bill about a committee to
study this I think there's just too many
irons in the fire all these things that
are brought up in this bill will I'm
sure get talked about when we work in
the subcommittee OR subsequent
bills further discuss forming uh
specialed funding in order to take some
of the weight off of localities but my
concern in this particular bill is that
it creates a seriously upside down
incentive structure whereby the state
provides all of funding but the local
districts provide all of the approvals
um and I believe that could turn out in
a in a very bad uh fiscal spiral that
wouldn't ultimately help further
discussion from the committee of
Representative
Damon thank you Mr chair I would
encourage people to not support the itl
we have been not making progress with
special ed
funding for 30 years this may not be the
perfect bill but it needs to go forward
while the other work is being done at
least at this point in the
process further
discussion represent
mil yes so I'm going to oppose the itl
on the motion on the basis that I think
that should be put at least into INF
study uh we have uh dealt with uh
specialed issues on this committee uh
for years without really ever looking at
it and I know that we have a pending
bill that's going to be coming before us
that looks that will look at the total
thing and I I
understand that uh this is part of that
total thing and my sense is I would
rather put this into inm study and from
a policy standpoint from this committee
indicate that this is an important issue
that must be dealt with uh even and by
putting an interim study it sits there
and then when the other hopefully the
commission will uh pass and this then
can be brought back as a topic for that
commission to deal with so I I would I
would encourage enage you to vote no on
the itl with an alternative motion of
interim study to follow that thank
you on 1670 not see any uh Madam clerk
would you please call the
RO Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative orell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 10 represent M
recognize for a motion yes I'd like to
put forward the interim study motion
thank you I'll second
it discussion from the
maker uh I think I've said my words I I
have no discussion either further
discussion from the
committee Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corell yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Balon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon
no and chairman lad
yes 19 Ys one nay good with
consent yes yes thank
you all right um
1634 everybody's here
y
representative leus you're recognized
for our
motion thank you I would like to move
ought to pass on 1634 is there a
second represent Ford seconds the motion
motion made by represent leus represent
leus would' like to speak to your
motion yes thank
you this is universal elig ibility for
the education Freedom account
and the legislature has decided that we
should fund
education and we keep hearing over and
over that all students are ours and all
students should get a good
education um and so I would like to
submit that this would be a way for all
students to get a good education
such that any student for whom their zip
code
assigned school public school is not
working not to say that it's a bad
school but it's not working for them
that they would have the option of
coming up with what does work for them
whether that's a neighboring Public
School a charter school a private school
home school college or some combination
of all of those that this would be the
way to help ensure that all kids get a
good education thank you thank you does
the second want to make any
discussion not hearing any
um ref Miley uh thank you Mr
chair we have uh five voucher bills
before before this committee so I'm only
going to say this
once uh um we have been uh the minority
here has been very patient around the
voucher issue we've not put put forward
a
repeal we have put forward in last year
and also this year several guideline
bills each one of those guideline bills
have been summarily
defeated we are dealing with a program
here that is a very costly program that
frankly takes money away from public
education
it's unfortunate that this kind of a
program does not have any gu guard rails
we' tried to work within the system to
provide those guard rails but they've
been summarily
dismissed this is opening this Universal
program and the others that you have
with the exception of the one that's
coming forward with that moves it from
350 to uh
500 this program was purported by the
Department of Education as a a program
that would help impoverished children
get a voucher to go to a school of their
choice this basically changes the intent
of the original program and frankly when
it was just initially advocated we said
well this is just the camel's nose Under
the
Tent well the camel is now within the
tent it's no longer under the nose of
the tent it is in the
tent so I'm not going to speak any
further on
vouchers because you know where we are
we know where you are you know where we
are my senses let's just move to vote
and fight it on the floor I concur on
that and I concur that with the other
EFA bills are coming up too let's just
get to the point and when the with the
person makes that motion just say no and
second not and we're just going to move
right to the to the vote so
any further discussion I want to limit
somebody that really has an urge thank
you very much uh so we have a motion the
floor it's OTP on HB
1670 1634 I was jumping up on
1634 Madam Kirk when you're ready we're
ready Vice chairman CL Deli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
tenner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman left yes 10 y 10 y motion yes
represent
itl second we have a motion made by
represent Miler second by represent luno
any further discussion on the bill not
seeing any when you're ready Madam
clerk this is 1634 motion is
itl U Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler no
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison I'm
sorry representative
Heath representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10 y I need
to okay we have a a 1010 on that so the
makers of the Motions will do
the their their
report we'll move on to the next bill HB
this is relative to qualifications for
student eligibility in the education
Freedom accounts
program and looking
yep representative McDonald you're
recognized for a motion thank you Mr
chair I move aop
pass and is there a second I'll second
pardon me Representative pel makes a
second representative McDonald makes the
motion the motion is ought to pass on
uh Madam any further discussion from
either not seeing that when you're ready
Madam clerk it's going too
fast take your time yes that's right we
want to make sure all that stuff's
right Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
vure yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Coro yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heath
no Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman Le yes
10 y 10 n
represent M move to
itl and we have a motion made by
representative Miler uh itl and
represent luno second represent Tanner
second that motion yes thank
you and
uh when we're ready when you're ready R
CLK
Vice chairman cordelli no Representative
leus no representative Ford no
representative Belcher no representative
dry yes oh excuse me no are you all
right representative we're just going
too fast representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pel no Representative corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
days obviously we don't want on consent
do
we Okay uh next bill which we have is
1665 this bill is relative to student
eligibility for the education Freedom
accounts
program another EFA bill I recognize
represent cordelli for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I would like to move out
to pass on
1665 we're moving yeah we're we're
moving too fast here y sorry what is the
number
1665 it's hard to get through those with
dry hands isn't it you
yeah
yeah okay go
ahead yes I would like to move ought to
pass on House Bill
1665 and I'll second
it any further discussion on HB
1665 motion was made by represent
cordelli second by represent lad for a
motion of
OTP when you're
ready pleas chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative Balon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad
yes ten y 10 motion representative Miler
move to itl Sir second second represent
seconds the motion for itl made by
represent miler
[Music]
itl
1665 right right to vote yes go
ahead Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble all
that no representative Pell no
Representative corello no representative
Miler oh yes representative cor
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon oh yes chairman
lad uh no 10 y 10
Nays oh
yeah
okay slow down so
Celli
and represent Luna is doing the yeah
okay so let me get this straight on on
these efas the first one 1634 was alus
is doing
the pass ought to pass and and who's
doing and represent Miler okay give copy
okay you got that okay yeah okay I got I
got the
others
okay
um
1553 make motion okay I'd like to jump
to uh HB 1553 that is an early
Bill 1553 yeah you got to get to it too
paper control time
here paper clipping
time
this is a bill relative to establishing
a pilot program under the Department of
Education to offer spelling to
communicate services to students with
autism and phasia I have a motion
represent M you recognize for a motion
I'd like to it all this motion please
I'll second it
further
discussion from the the maker of the
motion um you know uh we thank you Mr
chair we looked at this and obviously
the parents that were
here um had a significant impact on
their CH there's no question about that
uh the issue though I think that we
doubt with the pathologist the speech
pathologist that was here that it's just
one of many programs that are out there
and that to just to identify one program
here for this kind of a pilot uh we
thought was just unnecessary so I I I
would urge you to itl this thank
you and I I'll uh indicate that ashes
come out strongly against this they're
opposed to it as well as I think there
are some issues with the
the I'll call it the science behind it
uh so represent belard did you have your
hand up
yes thank you Mr chair I I'm going to
not support the itl motion on this and
here's why I will freely admit that
within this program by the introduction
of a second party to help somebody
communicate you introduced the implicit
possibility of bias that can happen
however all of the testimony that we
heard against this bill hinged on a
judgment that said that essentially if a
person cannot communicate autonomously
it's inappropriate to introduce a second
person to help them to communicate but
that's not a technical matter that is a
value judgment it's a value judgment I
disagree with because I believe it's
possible that there is a percentage of
this population that is incapable of
with our current technology and and
knowledge communicating autonomously
effectively but they may have some
ability to communicate with an
intermediary and with a second person
involved I think we should give those
people the opportunity by giving them
this pilot program to see if we can
gather some data that that demonstrates
this might be effective uh and finally I
I don't think that value judgment is up
to these organizations to make I think
that's up to us to make it thank you
further discussion representa Celli uh
thank you we've talked about things
being
evidence-based and I don't think at this
point um this program is evidence-based
and we've heard testimony to that um you
know
I've been behind many special education
bills so
um you know this this is a difficult
vote for me but um you know I had
firsthand testimony from my daughter
who's a special ed teacher about someone
doing this program the parents saying
that their child was writing novels
using this approach but when the parent
brought that child to my teacher's
classroom the child couldn't pick out
letters on the letter board but yet the
parents said she was writing novels with
this other teacher who was um uh helping
her use the letter board uh so I think
there's too many questions in my mind um
I think there's research going on um I
don't know that if it's I don't know
that it's uh dependent on us to find to
fund a pilot project um districts could
uh TR have someone trained now and try
it out on their own
uh so that is the reason for my uh
vote further discussion representa Damon
thank you I just want to say that I'm
going to reluctantly support the itl
because we don't have the evidence it's
not science-based enough at this
point however I keep thinking that this
might
be like Lorenzo's Oil if people remember
that it was a documentary movie and it
reported decades
later on a couple of parents I believe
they were
neuroscientists whose son was profoundly
epileptic he had you know three dozen
seizures a day and they ultimately
proved against all scientific
odds that eating
a 90% fat diet diminish the frequency of
seizures in a certain population of
epileptics and so so anyway without
going on and on I wonder if in some
years to come this will be a standard
practice I do support the IDE itl
because we don't have the Science
Now repand
Dr thank you Mr chairman um just the
fact that we don't have very many
anecdotes and we don't have data um
makes me want to not support the itl
because I think this is a pilot program
that will have eyes on it that can bring
us some data if we don't have data a
pilot program is the way to get
it perhaps
leus we keep talking about thinking
outside the box and this is thinking
outside the box and so it seems to me
like it would be wrong to vote against
this when this is an opportunity to try
something that might
work representative cascaden thank you
Mr chair um just in talking to a
specialist in the field
um that are really highly qualified um
this is a program that obviously seemed
to work with some of the adults that
were presented here but I was
transitioning the method of this program
which is facilitated
communication with a 6 7 8 9 10 year old
and it requires physical reinforcement
in other words you might have to take
the kid's hand and place it and you tell
me what kind of parent would say it's
okay to grab your kids' wrist so they
can learn the spelling board at this
point I can't support it for those
reasons because the examples that were
given were
adults they weren't kids um that's
something to be careful about thank you
thank you and I'm just going to tack in
on it my my own daughter is a speech
pathologist audiologist uh from univers
South Carolina Charles medical school
she works in schools with the prek 1 two
three um she has seen this rapid
responding type program work and it
echoes what you just said represent
cascaden and there is there's a lack of
science behind it and she sees a lack of
productivity from it as well and so for
that reason I believe that these
professionals that have their
seas and they're highly trained this
area of instruction uh I'm going to go
along with those professionals thank you
further discuss represent parel I'm
sorry I don't really want to believe
labor this point however I do want to
say because I thought I was actually in
support of this bill um that
representative cascaden testimony just
um made a very good point that we were
um hearing from adults who we don't know
how much education or input they had had
their entire lives and then maybe this
was finally the piece
of information that they needed to help
them communicate um so I'll be voting
itl is there any further discussion not
seeing any hands Madam clerk would you
please call the
RO the motion is it pardon
me the motion is itl on
1553 thank you you're welcome
Vice chairman cordelli yes
Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald
no representative Noble no
representative Pell
yes Representative corello no
representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative resentative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman
lad
yes 2 three four five six seven just one
moment
please six 7 8 9 10 11 12 what did I do
oh I see what I did wrong
okay it's like that doesn't add
up 13 y seven days I started with two
there that was it's just modern
math lce method okay okay the final
final vote was what 13 137 137 yeah the
the motion passes
itl okay is there a Minority Report
will there be a Minority Report
yes from
whom no you're in the majority you're in
the majority I'm what I'm major oh was
IDE sorry it's long I didn't change my
mind it took a long time all right write
the report for majority okay Bel will
write the uh Minority
Report okay okay
okay I where we are here
what okay
um the other early Bill we have is 1570
but we are waiting for an amendment on
that as well
so I think this takes care of those
early bills which we did have to do
today
right so then we'll go right to the top
of the docket we'll go to
117 yeah why you take
over this is House Bill 110 7
and on that did we have one handed out
already yeah we do have an amendment I
have an amendment right here which we
had talked about uh a
definition I wonder if there was
anything
else yeah yeah okay House Bill 1107 is
relative to school curriculum Frameworks
and I call on uh chairman lad for a
motion uh yes I'd like to move
OTP second representative
Miler I as maker I'd like to also offer
an amendment
110 or uh
045h I'll pass that
around
that
way uh as that's going around I'll just
speak very briefly to the
bill we talked about it me to the
amendment to the amendment the there
there was some discussion regarding uh
the definition which was down in the
bottom part of that bill online excuse
me 28 29 and 30 it didn't really Echo
what had been said elsewhere in the bill
uh I I think that this conversation is
very accurate this uh is an amendment
defining the curriculum framework
curriculum framework means an organized
plan of study that serves as a guide and
reference to what New Hampshire students
should know and be able to do in a
learning area and identifies the
academic standards for each learning
area pursuant to RSA 190 uh 3 E2 a Roman
1 a so what it does it's it's um takes
from what we're talking about uh the the
curriculum Frameworks up earlier in the
bill what students should know and be
able to do and as a dentified in the
substantive criteria for an adequate
education that's referenced uh it
establish the academic standards the AC
academic standards will be incorporated
into the curriculum Frameworks and
specifically stated as the academic
standards so I believe that's the whole
gist of the amendment and this is ought
to pass on the amendment correct yeah
did we even I did not get that did I
right thank you very much um so I'd like
to Mo make a motion otpa on the
amendment sir second by representative
Miler uh any further discussion on the
amendment
no yes representative Tanner thank you I
I'm just um wondering
why or if it makes any difference that
in the original it said a line guide for
instruction that is aligned with the
academic standards
versus um serves as a guide and
reference that's in the um
Amendment are you are you looking at
line four on the amendment is
that line 20 sorry I'm looking at line
29 in the original Bill and then I'm
looking at um line four that says it
serves as a guide and reference um
rather than that the instruction shall
be aligned um align seems to be taken
out of the amendment and I'm just
wondering if it you know how that makes
a
difference and is that difference
significant well I I'll respond to that
where the curriculum frame works are
according to this definition must
identify the academic standards and
academic standards are approved by the
State Board of Education for the
specific
subjects that 1932a speaks to I can only
assume that academic standards would be
built upon the subject
areas and that's just basic you know and
and it doesn't speak to instruction but
instruction and curriculum and
assessment all have to be aligned that's
just good best practice so I would say
the word aligned is is a a best practice
and uh it should be clearly
understood any further you're not going
to develop curriculum Frameworks that
this the curriculum Frameworks are
developed by the
department and academic standards as
well so they they they work hand in hand
followup followup just to me aligned
means that what's in
legislation um kind of predicts what's
going to be in the Frameworks or is the
basis for the Frameworks whereas this is
it it serves as a guide and
reference rather than has to be aligned
so that's that's where I have a little
hiccup on
it any further yes represent
Damon thank you
it seems to me that using the word align
is a stronger
statement of what's trying to be
achieved
in section
D and I'm wondering Mr chair if you
would
entertain an amendment to the amendment
or a new amendment that does in include
a lined in there I I think the amendment
is helpful in being more specific in
some ways
but I I think not having the word
aligned makes it not as
strong any further discussion on the
amendment so you would say to do in a
learning area and identifies the
academic standards aligned for each
learning
area aligned with each learning area yes
okay I have no problem with that if we
want to get an amendment I'm willing to
do that
is
um is the representative CAD you had
your hand up first uh thank you um the
curriculum Frameworks in in the uh major
disciplines that were developed were
state task force that included a variety
of people on it throughout the state and
I mean in my 45 years that was some of
the best guidance that school districts
had and from there they could develop
their programs their curriculum it all
filtered back to the curriculum
Frameworks what I'm um concerned about
and would like to know whether this bill
will move things
forward is a social I spoke to a
gentleman from stratum who served on the
social studies curriculum which was a
very difficult one compared to say
science and then they adopted The Next
Gen Science curriculum and then they
tailored it the reading was a state task
force the math was a state task force
and was updated when we added Algebra 1
but the social studies has lingered and
this gentleman who was on this Statewide
task force so they completed their work
and delivered it to be acted on and that
was 5 years ago and not a thing has been
done since that so I think it's
important that somehow this bill does
require at least in the four main
categories of English English reading
math social stud science we have those
Frameworks for school districts to then
build their programs because then you've
got some consistency because we're all
taking the state test but it really
doesn't tell the districts what program
to buy what curriculum to use they were
Broad and it's what we wanted every
single student in New Hampshire to know
and be able to do no matter where they
went to school and it's important we
keep that in mind is all children um so
I'm hoping that this this bill and I do
support it obviously um because it's a
very important tool to help education in
the whole state should be um delivered
in a sense so thank you thank you uh
rent Woodcock thank you repres cell um I
just want to follow up on represent C
Caden's comment I don't think we should
hold off on a change of a word because I
don't think the word is as relevant as
the attend of the bill um it's on the
table and it's I think it should pass
but I do want to Echo and I just talking
in my P here at to the right these
things some of these are 20 years old
Department of Education hasn't done
anything in 20 years you mean to tell me
the 203 Health Frameworks nothing's
happened in 20 years the field of health
so I agree this this is well needed
we're talking 10 15 years old and
they're doing nothing over there I just
think it needs to be clear in terms of
the curriculum development this is we're
basing everything on curriculum and
structure and assessment and we use
information 20 years old that's all but
I do agree appreciate representative lad
moving this forward thank you
representative lad yeah I I concur uh
the Frameworks certainly serve as a
guide and a reference for instructors in
the field and for when you are
identifying the curriculum to teach
these academic standards that's a local
responsibility but the academic
standards are the the guide for all this
um
I I also feel that we're operating on
curriculum Frameworks that are ancient
history 2003 we're talking about health
2006 we're talking social studies uh the
recent ones which have been identified
are the mathematics and the science Next
Generation science those are current and
and appropriate however uh the other
areas were lagging I I kind of disagree
a little bit with what represent
cascaden said that those four or five
main subjects they're all main subjects
to me physical education Health that
they all need a curriculum framework
they need to have academic standards
clearly stated within giving direction
to our people in the field so I have no
problem with putting aligned in here um
I don't think it's the the key is that
we are identifying academic standards
will appear will be identified in the
Frameworks I think that's the biggest
key to the whole thing would would
represent mil yeah would this uh I'm
looking at line four on the
amendment if it were to read as guide
and
reference uh be aligned with what
students should know you would add be
aligned with does
that yeah okay
I'll Tanner so I think aligned is a
active verb so you have to do something
rather than just identify look at it and
say oh yeah identify it or Define it and
I think what I what it what it says to
me is that in the original Bill okay and
I understand the you know what students
need to know and able to do in the
learning area that's that's fine but it
says that it is aligned with academic
standards for each learning area
pursuant to RSA 193 whatever aligned
means that it's got to be set up it when
people look at it it it's they've got to
make a judgment or not a judgment but an
act of
um activity that actually puts one the
Frameworks with the standards
identifying it just means well okay so
this is the standard and we're
identifying something in in the
Frameworks um I just think it to me it's
it's an important difference in in that
sentence and that's why I'm making a big
deal about it thank you representative
Heath thank you for taking my question
it's kind of more of a comment in a
question um many years ago working at
the department we spent hours doing
curriculum work we had curriculum
specialists at the department of Ed that
brought together and led these
conversations across our state involved
teachers
administrators it's my understanding
that right now at the department there
are no curriculum people we don't have a
math curriculum person we don't have
science um the last one I believe was
Marsha mcaffrey who was the Arts and she
was not replaced when she left so my
question is if if we're going to put
this in place um who's expected to do
this work
EXC question represent
L that's a very good question we are
curriculum shallow at the Department of
Education absolutely I'm I'm a little
discouraged on that in the school
district I worked in in
Alaska the curriculum Department took
care of this whole
floor and we had peep specialists in all
area right down to Media
Services uh gifted and talented the
whole n yards and I think that the the
Department's struggling with the
allocation of dollars which we have and
to to support curriculum and they just
don't have that available they need to
make those those decisions we have asked
I have asked numerous times to folks
that testify what are your priorities
for the budget policy-wise I've never
ever gotten a response never from from
Department this goes back over multiple
Commissioners as well so I I I I can
remember having that Frank discussion
with commissioner
Barry and with Paul leather who was one
that was very engaged in
mathematics so um I you know I have no
problem in amending this uh but where I
think if you're going to do it the it
has to be at the the academic standards
aligned with each learning area to
that's where I put it rather than the
front side because the front side the
curriculum Frameworks would serve as a
reference and guide incorporating those
standards which are aligned with the
with the subject areas in
statute um so I I I I think that we got
to be very careful where we put this I
wouldn't put in the front side I put it
right in line five right after academic
standards aligned with each learning
area pursuant
to so uh representative lad um is it
your intention to uh submit an amendment
um based on this discussion absolutely
we could you
know stop this bill right where it is I
could hand this to
Jen and she can
call okay um if there's no objection uh
representa
Damon I have a different comment than
the topic about alignment so I don't
know if I should forward with that at
this moment or not um pertains to
Amendment right why we hold off and
we'll do all the Amendments at the same
time then when we get this one back okay
what was your comment thank
you so I'm appreciating the value of the
curriculum Frameworks and I'm also
concerned that putting this bill forward
when there seems to be consensus that
the existing curriculum framew
Frameworks in most topic areas are very
dat
should there perhaps be included in this
bill a requirement for them to be
updated on some particular frequency
every five or 10 or whatever years
because otherwise we're saying align
with health standards from 2003 I mean
that doesn't seem like what we
want ruption of
lead there there I think we have several
issues which we have to
address and we we can say we want to
have Emergency Management plans in at a
certain date they don't come so what
what 20% came and then after Perry
plumber got on them we got 50 something
B then we got 80% after we threatened
they wouldn't get any money um the same
thing occurs in the curriculum areas
though there there's going to have have
to be a concerted look at the by the
State Board of Education which they're
the ones to approve these academic
standards do we have the staff necessary
to make this work and what kind of
budget are we going to present to the
legislature to request the dollars to do
this Excuse me yes go ahead so I you
know I I think but it's time
for this is this is core to what we're
doing in schools this is Centric to it
and and I feel that this is one of the
reasons why we see some scattered
achievement scores throughout the state
because I don't think many people are
really provided here's what we have to
teach they're not looking back at 2003
they're not looking at 2006 or even 2008
Frameworks which they were all done
those various times except the recent
ones so they're looking for guidance and
if if we want kids coming out knowing
this stuff out of school then we have to
we have to be on top of this I think
it's got to be a responsibility the
state board and the department
requesting through their approp their
budget each year and I will go to
representative you know Heath's
committee on finance support
it we've had that discussion before when
we wanted counselors in the school to
help us with the CTE
programs and I don't know if that's
hitting it either anymore because we're
still at the same 177% of our students
participating in CTE we need at least
double
that so uh I I think by it it's it's I
understand what you're saying represent
Damon but I I think that we have to the
state board has to recognize this is an
issue and along with the administration
at the at the Department of Education
and and and and and um move on it I
don't think more legislation is going to
make it work representative Woodcock i'
like to comment on the on both of these
I'm not I agree represent will add uh
that has to be done and and it should be
done quickly I don't agree however that
the budget is the answer to this this
has not been a priority of
doe they got a gazing priorities but
culum instruction and assessment aren't
the three and they're the fundamental
piece of education and that's the part
we can go we all the all the budget they
have the budget they prioritize that
this is not a priority Department of
Education that's the unfortunate part
you're exactly right represent lad 2003
doesn't make
it the issue is that what subjects do we
assess Reading Writing arithmetic
science every so many years so we have
next Generation science we have language
arts reading standards current we have
math
current social studies isn't tested
right so it's it's in the back seat so
we went the route of trying to have a
commission look at how we're going to
teach Civics we put it in law you will
have a halfe course in Middle School a
halfe course in the high school and you
will embed this in grades K through 7 or
six embed
Civics what are we doing about the
curriculum now we have a commission
looking at it we're going to get a
textbook um I agree with you well it's
not that's not going to hack it either
because it's not going to identify the
academic standards for K through
12 representative
lakus I'm very
confused we keep saying that curriculum
is a is local control and yet now we're
having this conversation about how the
doe isn't doing
curriculum well Frameworks I know that's
what this bill is about but you you guys
were talking about curriculum and so
that's why
I'm confused I thought that was a
local can I respond to that quickly
there's a difference between what you're
talking about the the curriculum is a
responsibility of the local they want to
use hoton Mifflin silver bdet or some
other kind of box program that they can
do that or write their own
program the subjects which we're talking
about are those criteria inadequate
and those have academic standards that's
what we're addressing the academic
standards once we establish that then we
provide these curriculum Frameworks
which are model guidance and reference
type Frameworks for the schools to maybe
Echo use or say well we're going to take
this and incorporate it in but see I I
when you read the curriculum Frameworks
that I've looked at I kind of wander
through trying to find out where the
academic standards they're sort of
immersed within and you have to really
kind of filter that out they're not
clearly stated the academic standards
for teaching the American Revolution are
here and they're stated within social
studies or whatever thing you're doing
in Civics and how to communicate and
live together so there there's a
difference between curriculum and
instruction that's all local totally
local this is the way the state helps
provide assistance to the districts and
then showing them here the academic
standards which you integrate into your
which guide your curriculum purchases
rep l so thank you very much Mr chair
and with um all due respect to what
represented lad was was just saying as
far as curriculum being 100% local no I
mean we've seen the Department of
Education get get kneed deep involved in
curriculum and Prager you as a as as
curriculum for personal financial
literacy I think is a prime example of
that now if we had a curriculum
framework for personal financial
literacy that most schools would would
be a um a one semester um class
requiring a student to
[Music]
be how how many hours is a one semester
class 30 hours maybe of uh of of inclass
time as opposed to 15 4 and 1 half
minute um videos which is what Prager
you I think a curriculum framework would
probably lay out um uh something for
personal financial literacy that Prager
you doesn't even come close to covering
and I think this goes to representative
woodcock's point is that the uh the
commissioner had zero interest in um in
developing curricular Frameworks
because their ability I do not want to
their ability to develop curriculum it's
talk about the department talk about you
know Administration but I don't want to
hear specific individuals because it's
there is an issue we do not have
curriculum staff over there I I totally
agree with you on that
representative represent
cascad thank you um I consider myself to
have a lot of patience sometimes um the
thing that is
disheartening is that every single
person in your
seat wants students educated no matter
how and the problem that we have
entailed is a strong
division right some are fighting for one
kind some are fighting for another kind
and New Hampshire has a reputation
nationally to be a high standards
rigorous education system I've had
multiple students transfer in from other
states and they are nowhere near
prepared to New Hampshire students and
we have also had a numerous number of
graduates from our high schools from
some of our homeschool programs from our
religious schools that are doctors
lawyers are very
successful and when we go to a test
score you know that's only one day one
moment in time and they aren't as great
as we want them to be but if you know
human behavior there's a bell-shaped
curve you'll always have high Achievers
low Achievers middle Achievers but I
believe that the problem that we're not
doing well in test scores overall or
over time because you don't take one
year data as the tell all you got to
watch for a pattern is that the division
in this state is to fight for one kind
of education versus another and until we
all promote every child in this state
then we're going to continue to have
those divides and that's the
problem so um we we have a an amendment
being drafted currently um and uh
hopefully we can um get that before too
long bigon do this all again this right
yes right so let's um let's turn this
back over to Chairman lad let's take a a
break everybody stand up walk down the
hallway and visit the WC and we'll come
back and start this thing up a little
bit
here thank
you let's try to map a road where we're
going to go here because we have people
in and out
yeah
we have uh we're going to jump from the
bill that we on we leave that where it
was until we get the amending language
coming back um I want to just remind
everybody here that if we and I just
spoke to an individual walking down the
hallway that there is no such thing as
the perfect perfect
bill so what we need to recognize if
there's a word just one or two words
that we want to see change we have the
Senate we can work with to get that
stuff done we can sit here all day
talking about one word and we're going
to be sitting here during break time at
the end of the month when everybody else
is out skiing
and speak for yourself yeah we're so so
let's Let's
uh uh this the one she was going to put
the amendment in on so she who's
she is the amendment out no is that
Amendment back from your 1206 yet no
they said they got it and sent it
to take that well we we'd like to take
that because there one where we have
some agreement but 1058 for we okay
we're going to be discussing HP
1058 1058 is fail relative the school
employee and designated School volunteer
criminal history records checks
Mo and I recognize represent Myer for a
motion I move to itl is there a
second is there a second on
1058 rbson whitcock so we have a motion
made by repon Miler and second for uh
itl is that what it is yes yeah yeah and
second by represent Woodcock further
discussion represent
I have nothing to say pres
Woodcock anybody else have anything to
say mam
Clark motion is
itl representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pel
yes representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 19 yays one not
voting so it's 19 190 y righty consent
it be on consent obvious yeah y thank
you there you
go go down in
history
okay
111 yeah if I've got it back
yet Jen's not here I know they've got it
done it's already
filed yes yes yes so all you have to
take the analysis or something out of
the report and do it
um we can just start going down some
others
1066 we don't have agreement okay um we
have a number of bills which we have
amendments and they they're done I don't
have them in front of me so we'll try to
run those down over the break
here let's see no wait a minute I do
let's do um
being
relative the use of public school
infrastructure fund for energy efficient
school
buses going to hand the gabble over to
represent
cordelli uh thank you Mr chair um this
is House Bill 1161 relative to the use
of public school infrastructure fund for
energy efficient school
buses uh and I call on uh chairman lad
for a
motion uh yes I'd like to make the
motion of OTP is there a
second second second by representative
Pell um who would you like to speak to
your motion yes I'd like to offer
Amendment
H was did was that sent around to
everybody
174h the other
day Okay what this amendment does in
this section this is a public school
infrastructure structure fund and it
lists the items which these monies can
be used
for and the bill as it came struck out
energy efficient or excuse me struck out
the whole
line then I was advised at the
commission
meeting by a certain person at this
table that buses are infrastructure and
they are related to Public
Safety and surveillance and access
control and responding to by way of
cameras and equipment that might be
placed on these
buses and then the conversation went a
little further and said okay but this is
for energy efficient school buses the
question then maybe this should be
written so as school buses or other
vehicles used for transportation of
students so that we can put this
security stuff on any kind of
bus uh that where it's necessary so this
amendment strikes out the word energy
efficient and says school buses or other
vehicles used for transportation of
students I was contacted by the um oh
the uh Sierra Mountain Club want to know
why are you um taking away something
that's energy
efficient and that's not the intent of
what we're trying to do here the intent
is to try to support safety and this
whole area of public school
infrastructure we've been working with
that since 2018 there's a task force
report back in 2018 it was was done by
the governor and a task force which was
chaired by um Perry plumber director
plumber of Homeland Security and I wrote
out 48 plus recommendations of what we
need to do to make our schools more
secure and safe and healthy environment
for the kids and and we've been working
towards that end and the monies which
we've been allocated by the
appropriation from the the state here
have been used towards that very very
purpose uh initially we had eate and we
kind of meshed it in a little bit with
Communications and the Federal grant
programs but we have really gravitated
towards making sure that every school
has had the opportunity apply and they
all have they all have and they've all
received grants the grants are up to
$100,000 per
project and we have allocated to date a
little over $50 million over these years
for school security
actually we were informed by Perry
plumber when he was the homeand that we
are spending more per pupil in this
state for security than other states
which were to be commended on but we're
not there yet folks and there's a lot
that we have to do and this past year we
allocated another $10 million that money
has already been uh we've received the
applications we're processing those
applications right now so we're trying
to keep this fund for the purpose and
the intent of what we're using it for
right now and that's the safety security
access control making sure Arctic entry
areas or entry areas to buildings are
there key codes all that safety glass
and we're making good strives but we
don't want to change course we want to
stay on course and make sure we get all
these
schools where they need to be I can't
discuss a whole lot of it because we're
doing that in closed session uh so I
think this is another and I really
myself I I missed missed these school
buses that is infrastructure and many
states infrastructure is school buses
and so we need to make sure that they
are safe and
secure so that's the purpose of this
bill and this that's the purpose of the
amendment right and that was not to pass
on the amendment correct yeah yeah I
know that was there a second was there a
second yes representative Pell wasn't it
oh any
comment on the amendment that was OTP
period motion on the amendment yeah so
yeah I got to the discussion again
without right right yeah moot so I'll
make that motion and who made the
second okay good okay again any comment
represent pel on the
amendment chairman lad did a fabulous
job I have nothing to add I talked too
long I
know so it's okay any yeah any further
comments from the committee on the
amendment 174 amend representive
Woodcock thank you CH than you chairman
cell I I just want to reiterate what
chairman L said to the extent that this
does not eliminate electric school buses
energy efficient school buses we know
from the speaker before there's only
seven in the state right now but I do
think we also need to keep our eye on
the Energy Efficiency so I appreciate
that thank
you anything further from the committee
seen nothing um Madam clerk U we could
um vote on the
amendment repres represenative cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 19 Ys no Nays one not
voting thank you um chairman lad do you
have a further motion yeah let's vote on
the
bill I recommend Bill be
otpa thank you is there a second
represent Pell thank you uh
any further comment on
otpa see none Madam
clerk representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes represent Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Boni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 Ys no Nays one not voting thank
you uh thank you
consent
great what about 1166 11 61 we can do we
have the amendment for that me 1166 1166
we have the amendment for
yeah okay we have an amendment on
1166 take that
out
yeah uh representative McDonald was that
uh handed out to everybody
yes
okayy this is House Bill 1166 adding an
exception from required Civics
competency assessments and a call on
chairman lad for a motion thank you very
much I'd propose uh OTP on
1166 second second by represent McDonald
just one any comment Mr chairman we need
to slow down a little bit yeah right
166 all right and that was OTP yes lad
and McDonald yes
okay's right that's
right yes represent McDonald do you have
a motion on the amendment yes I would
like to move forward Amendment 2024 03
free
H I'll second
it okay um representative M Donald would
you like to speak to your motion on the
amendment yes to speak briefly the
amendment just removes the Civil Air
Patrol from the original Bill we
recognize the importance of that program
however that is not a program available
within the school setting with school
funding and the intent of the bill is to
offer students partaking in civically
active school programs such as the
junior reserves officer training corpse
or
jrtc and that's the only change this
amendment
makes thank you anything I'm not going
to add we I think we discussed it the
difference between this program and
other programs is these are programs
which are uh uh adopted by the local
Board of Ed the school board uh there's
a a a criteria a curriculum established
uh it's different than any other area
and it's not extracurricular it's
curricular uh thank you any from the
committee see
none um Madam clerk when you're
ready this is on the amendment
0335 H okay
representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Miler
noes should I call
her represent corello representative
corello okay representative miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock
yes representative bbone U
representative Hall
no representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative
Damon
yes uh chairman lad yes 12 Ys eight
Nays thank you uh is there a further
motion I oppose
otpa for
second thank you um any further
comment
represent represent Miler thank you Mr
chair the is the issue here for for me
is
not uh negative against the program
that's at that question here that's
that's
not we have when when this originally
came
forward uh of having this uh High state
test given to kids before they have to
graduate we oppose
that and that's the basis of this
opposition to this is that if you do it
for one group why not another group
notwithstanding the academic program of
Ry Etc I support that
but we passes originally for all kids
regardless of the program that they're
in and this changes that uh that
supposition of the basis of that
original program and that's why I will
oppose this
motion chairman lad yeah
um when we put the
this test assessment the United States
citizenship Immigration Services
assessment in place initially we had
other local assessments which could be
done as
well and it's been changed to where we
are right now and as I said yesterday I
am not supportive of one test and I
think re cascad you mentioned this
earlier today one test is a shot in time
and it's not necessarily
reflection or
demonstration of of of student learning
and I believe that this program right
here where it is you know local board
approved it's it's an elective course
it's got the Civics criteria that's
necessary that we have incorporated into
our Civics education but most
importantly to me we measure this not
necessarily through a test and these
tests it I I don't think this United
States citizen Immigration Services
assessment is a measure of of our social
studies or CICS or government to begin
with and and and it doesn't have it
doesn't pass the criteria for being such
a test if we're going to have the same
questions over and over the 120
questions which I could go out and
memorize as well so it's not not a a a
test which is aligned with Civics I
believe in working with this Civics
commission rate this is more aligned
with what we're asking our young people
to come out of school
possessing and knowing how to work with
each other how to understand the
principles of this country and and how
to uh just function as United States
citizens should and they are learning to
volunteer they're working in communities
and they are if you've ever been in
school and looked at one of these R
Junior Ry programs is definitely doing
exactly what i' like to see every
student come out with and remember most
kids in this program are not going on in
the
military but they're acquiring this
information so again they got the
competencies so why not move forward
with this I think this is a great
opening the door saying there's more to
assessment of a juner than one test in
time and I we heard this from teachers
who spoke in front of this committee
over and over and over so I'll conclude
my my discussion on on that represent
Woodcock thank you repr Celli I want to
make two comments first off the reason I
supported the amendment was anything
that would get a student exempt from
this fictitious test I was supporting I
think I think the test has no value
citizenship test and I just heard
representative Milo who brought a
different philosophy to it and and opens
my mind a little bit more and I just
heard the chair say he agrees as well
that this test is not valid it's just
I'm shamee we have the damp test there
alt together I not supporting the motion
thank you represent Tanner um Dido the
last couple speakers plus the fact that
we've in the
legislation specified that it's the 2020
immigration test so by specifying a
certain date it gets more out to date
out of date every year that we provide
from this our underlying
RSA yeah represent luno thank you Mr
chair so so I'm I'm looking at
18911 in the um in our in our law books
here and so it it starts on page
466 and there's a lot to it and I think
um representative lad spoke to this a
lot to the instruction of civics in New
Hampshire and it's well um it's well
laid out talks about a halfe course um
talks about uh instruction in a number
of different areas and that's all part
of Roman 1 which is the bulk of 8911 and
then there's Roman 2 which this
amendment and this U this biller
directed to which is specifically
establishes the um the immigration and
naturalization uh test as being a
graduation requirement and um very
similar I mean we're going to we're
going to be talking about whether or not
the FAFSA should be a graduation
requirement but uh but at least we have
data that that points to the fact that
when students complete the FAFSA they
have a better understanding of personal
financial literacy and actually a better
understanding as to whether or not they
can afford to go to to college um I
agree with representative lad I think
what's what's laid out in Roman 2 um in
the statute now and certainly the
subject of this bill has absolutely no
bearing on um on what a student um
learns from their um their their Civics
instruction and um and I agree with what
represent Woodcock said that that it
could be taken out so would given the
fact that we're now in a in a situation
where we're looking to exempt students
from from the test why wouldn't we uh we
we just get rid of the test and rely
back on the um the the really the core
content that's laid out in
18911 uh as far as a strong Civics
education and would would would this
committee be interested in taking a look
at had an amendment that repeals Roman 2
so that's the qu a question that I'm
putting out there uh personally I I
would not uh but you're okay
exempting different different groups
represent
Damon thank you I fully support an
amendment to
remove the examination
requirement I've had multiple
conversations in my district about the
barriers to doing that
and I would parenthetically add if we're
not going to do that all of us sitting
in this room should have to pass that
test U any
further uh comments we have a uh I I I
have one last comment representative L
the the Civics curriculum that we speak
to the Civics requirement to teach a
half year in the middle school and a
half year in high school and then have
it taught embedded in the Elementary
grades that's that area of of the
academic standards now this citizenship
test is not an
assessment of that K through 12
framework and we're trying to put the
Frameworks back together and get in that
direction this assessment is a different
assessment I don't see this as an
assessment of how the kids are learning
in terms of civics and government and
history it's not it's absolutely not
all this is is an ex exemption from this
test which these students which are in
the rzi program
possess what we want them to know and be
able to do you don't know by taking this
test by by taking the assessment up top
that the kids are going to do this but
you know that the kids are doing in
Razzi do do
it that's the
difference and so if you truly want to
know if these students are functional as
citizens of our country I would look to
these youngsters that students that are
in in in this jrc program as that's one
way of doing it everybody has the option
of taking this elective course that they
so want to I would take it because I
think there's a lot to be learned in
leadership and and Etc within and being
a citizen in our country so I don't want
to construe that the assessment up top
is a measure of our social studies it is
not has not been aligned with the
academic standards at
all and this right here so you know I I
think that students that take the
opportunity to do this this is an
incentive for them to get into this
JROTC program if it's available in their
High School I think it's a
wonderful uh position to be in so I I I
just want to make that clarifying
definition that there's a difference
between this imigra immigration
test and thinking we're assessing
curriculum we're
not uh representative
cascaden uh thank you I would support a
repeal of this bill because when it
first came out it was another
legislative unfunded mandate as there
are
many and I think you need to trust the
system that they are teaching um Civics
in school
and this test does not really measure as
somebody said the curriculum in the
building so I would support repealing
this bill there there is a motion of
otpa on the floor already I won't uh any
further comments on
otpa represent mil and just a final
comment it would seem to me that that
this the passage of this would be an
ideal
recruitment incentive for
Ry right sure okay all right not just
not just that but you know for a person
who wants to acquire these citizenship
skills this is a good place to learn
though any further representative
Lun so so if I'm thank you Mr chair so
if I'm connecting the dots here that the
um that the um immigration
Naturalization test is not a Civics not
not an assessment of a student civics or
or government understanding and it's
not connected to any Frameworks any
curriculum Frameworks that are that are
laid out in um uh in
statute and that
where its
purpose through this amendment would be
to provide an
incentive for students to join um Junior
Rozi
then is it reasonable then to conclude
that that this um this test under Roman
2 this the immigration Naturalization
test is just a hurdle or it's an or an
obstacle it's an obstacle to graduation
it's to be avoided at any cost if if I
can join another student group that may
become on this list of Exempted groups
and I'm encouraged to join that student
group so that I don't have to take this
test it really begs the question what's
the purpose of the test and um and if
there's no purpose of the test if it is
not connected to um to the the the the
subst of content that we lay out in
18911 for a for for an adequate uh
Civics education and it's not tied with
any of the Frameworks and it's uh uh it
it doesn't seem to have any purpose at
all and and it would seem to me to make
that it would make a lot of sense to
rather than overburdening our public
schools with useless um U graduation
requirements I know we're going to be
talking about FAFSA later and I I think
FAFSA is a strong graduation requirement
for personality but this one appears to
be a useless graduation requirement that
uh that we should seriously consider
consider um uh removing uh all of Roman
2 from the statute um the uh
representative
McDonald thank you I take objection to
the claims that this test is useless
When you mention the RSA of the Civics
requirements in
schools you speak as if this has been in
statute for ages when this committee
passed the Civics
legislation last year so in the sense we
have not had a time to see the impacts
on it and to study if the impact of
requiring the half credit course has
been impactful so for some students this
may be the only exposure they have to
the Civics course we have had testimony
prior that stated that although it's a
high stakes test that there has not been
students that we know of have been
barred from graduation for not
completing or not passing this test so I
still think there is some value to the
test in itself I wouldn't say it's
useless
whatsoever thank you very much uh seeing
no further comments let's um move on uh
is this this is on the amend this is on
otpa correct let's stick to otpa
representative Hall sure thank you thank
you Mr chair um I have to say that my
first read of this bill it immediately
said to me these kids they're in a great
program I don't question that at all but
these kids probably wouldn't be able to
pass the test that's what it looks like
to me like why we're exempting them
because they can't sit for however long
it takes to take an hour I don't know
how long it takes to take the test but
it really suggests that we want to
exempt them so they don't have to take
the test and if they don't have to take
the test is because it's going to impact
a graduation I don't know it just
reads like it reads like we got to get
them out of that test and this is one
way to get it and like I say the program
is fantastic but um thank you
representative uh see no further
comments um uh Madam clerk um we can
take a roll call vote on otpa thank
you representative cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes Representative beler
no representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell
no representative
Corell
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no and chairman lad
yes eight Ys 12
n make a
motion is there a further
motion I guess I'm
move uh representative Miler you have a
motion thank you Mr chair I move to
itl
second I'll second represent Tanner
second
any discussion representative Miler no
thank
you no I'm thanks any discussion from
the
committee seeing none Madam
clerk motion is
itl representative cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative beler yes agre
representative dry no
representative McDonald
no representative Noble
no representative
Pell
yes representative
Quello representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
12 y 8
n okay we're going to take a it's lunch
time so we're GNA break for
lunch I just got the amendment oh
got says
1266 oh we've got a bunch of amendments
so yeah we we'll uh we'll break for
lunch right now and we'll come back at
12:45 okay 45 minute
launch okay which ones have we done
today okay um you start
from yeah okay
15 16
y
1561 yeah 1561 yeah Y and 1665 right M
10588 yeah 1553
1639 we already we skip those so those
were done yeah 1166 yeah 1161 okay good
so we did verify that my pink sheet so
we
did one two three four five six 78 nine
10 this morning that's not bad that's
not bad um now two of us are going to be
out at 130 yeah I know it and um one of
them is my bill so we'll have to take
that up maybe after I get back yeah yeah
so we got look at what bills we want to
take up right after
lunch nice view
what yeah see yeah when we
had
e
even though we don't have all the folks
back in here yet uh we're uh dealing
with
1107 this is relative to Public School
curriculum
Frameworks and I'm going to hand the
gavl over to representa
cordelli I like to be recognized uh
thank you Mr chairman this is a
continuation of HB 1107 that we started
this morning and we're awaiting a um
another amendment and we have that now
so I recognize um uh representative lad
CU we had a uh pending motion on the old
Amendment don't yes it is
0145 okay uh I would like to pull the
amendment that I had previously we put
the motion for OTP on that's
045h the old Amendment it hasn't been
passed around
yet and
okay there we are so having the floor
now I would like to introduce uh another
amendment for this is the curriculum
framework
spill and this amendment is
0344 I recommend OTP on
that is there a
second okay oh you mean you need to look
at it
okay that's
loud would would you like to talk about
the amend yeah is there a second no
there's not a second so all I'm going to
say is says the language we had talked
about the academic standards aligned
with each learning area aligned with is
the
change
representative Damon had
seconded okay re recognize me
yes so we had a discussion on on this
amendment it's been it's been the motion
was made by myself right and um
representative Damon had seconded it I
don't know if you heard before no it was
seconded over here by represent Miler
okay this is a new
Amendment okay this is
0344 H and just to speak to the
amendment it defines curriculum
framework and it just makes out couple
word change that we had recommended or
thought talked about on the previous
amendment that the learning area and
identifies the academic standards align
with learning areas pursuant to the RSA
so okay um further comment by anyone on
the committee representative Tanner yes
I think this amendment makes this still
much stronger thank
you further comment no see none um I
believe we have
the motion of OTP on
0344 and a second so Madam we on the
amendment on the amendment right otpa
this is otpa oh this is ad this is OTP
on the amendment
right
okay Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative babon yes
representative cascan yes representative
Damon yes and chairman lad yes 20 a z
n would there be a further motion repr
motion of otpa on 1107 Second second by
President Miler um further discussion by
anyone on the committee no seeing none
Madam clerk whenever you're ready she's
fine
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corell yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative tenner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20
a0 consent good we're good so got one
done yay
yeah all righty where are we going next
here
okay have two have to leave 115 130
sometime so yeah
yeah just consent then right yes that
was on that was on consent yes um we
just work our way down and
now
do we have the one from Alicia yeah we
have the amendment yes okay which bill
is that that was
um
1206 okay we're going to take up uh Bill
next okay who was making a
[Music]
motion D yes uh represent you care make
a
motion 126 my motion
is my motion is to uh
itl
okay we have a motion made to itl 1206
is there a second representative
Cornell
Thank uh is there any discussion on the
bill no I have discussion on the bill
yes the objection that people keep
objecting to is part Roman numeral 5
which is lines 25 and
26 the uh code of conduct part of it and
I did an amendment that completely takes
that out but of course if we itl then I
can't introduce the
amendment Is there further discussion on
the bill yes represent Cornell I would
just like to be on the record to say
that it's not just section five that I
object to but most of the
bill represent
cordal and I would just be go on the
record of saying I'm going to um vote
against itl because I see this is a very
big problem from my years of teaching
um I um I remember um a former student
of mine meeting her later she was
running for a political office and I was
helping her with her campaign and she
was extremely surprised because um she
thought I was of the other party and
because of the fact that just based on
the fact that I was an English teacher
in a college so I'm not going to say
which party or anything you can kind of
guess for yourself but um what I said to
her was um you know I I I I didn't think
it was appropriate to have my any of my
political views obvious in class and I
always strove to avoid doing that and I
see this as a bill that just would make
that something that should be done by
all
teachers so um
I am just wanted to explain why I was
Voting against
itl further
discussion just want to express my
concern in the words Theory and ideology
a very uh one man's theory is not not
another and based upon what um I I think
that this is not has not clarified some
of the terminology used in there which
makes it sort of ambiguous to me and I
think it's going to cause problems uh
within within teaching in
schools uh so for that
reason the code is out that's good but
the still it's uh it's uh needs a lot of
work further
discussion representa Tanner thank you I
think that uh not only is it a vaguely
worded build but um we haven't had any
problem demonstrated here and so what it
event what it really does is it puts it
out there is that the default is that
teachers are indoctrinating and that's
so grossly wrong that um it's hard to
imagine and it becomes an insulting bill
for teachers so I agree with um
representative Cornell I object to
everything in it thank you further
discussion are you ready to call Ro mam
CL
the the bill is HB
2206 relative prohibiting educator
indoctrination and the motion on the
table is
itl vice chairman
cordelli yes Representative leus no
representative
Ford
yes representative
beler yes
representative dry
no representative McDonald yes
representative
Noble yes representative Pell
yes representative
Corel Coro no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman L yes 17 three
nce any objections to consent
yes you'll be writing minity
report so the minority would report
would be
OTP
yes
okay like to now go
to HB
1165 1165
this is a bill
uh I get to the
bill the deals with school building Aid
and the procedures for
that I'd like to pass the grav over to
you
okay this is House Bill
1165 relative to procedures for school
facilities under the Department of
Education I call on uh representative
lad for a motion I thank you Mr chair
I'd like to uh put forth the motion
OTP
second representative Ford
seconds uh discussion representative lad
yes and I'd like to put forth uh
Amendment which is coming around we just
got it back uh 0322 h
to pass as H to
pass than is there a
second okay who second represent Ford
had his hand we've got
a practice practice passing
paperwork yes
more I think there's probably ext's
going that way
then
than do you want me to speak to it now
yes uh yes represent okay so I I will
speak to
0322 and explain uh what we've done here
uh you can see the highlighted areas
where we're talking about an owner's
project manager this is you remember
this is the language that came from the
Department of Education
and um so the person that's acting like
a clerk of the works has to be the
owner's person not the contractor's
person which is very very dangerous when
it comes to change orders which are
expensive then we go down to the public
school infrastructure area and where we
have put in there the general court
recognizes that there is a need to
provide funding for infrastructure
projects for public
preschools El Elementary and secondary
schools
um they didn't do this
right no it's not what we sent over if
it said uh Public elementary and public
secondary
schools for well maybe that's the way
projects for public preschools okay the
commas are there okay thank goodness for
that and then going on to the back page
there on Roman
three
uh
the um May authorize the department to
fund
expenditures for the following
purposes uh the public school
infrastructure commission may yeah okay
um and then underneath that they they're
changing the date um and they struck out
remember in Roman 4 where we had struck
out in the first time the first meeting
of the commission shall be called by the
first named House member that's back in
the first meeting of the commission
shall be held within 45 days of
effective date of the section that's
back in the commission shall meet at
least monthly that's out because the
commission does not meet monthly and
cannot meet monthly then I believe there
is on the bottom in line 18 a
recommendation that came I think that
came from representa
Damon the Department of Education shall
notify every Public School in New
Hampshire how to access the United
States Environmental Protection Agency
Tools for Schools program and shall
encourage public schools to implement
and uh the program to help provide and
maintain good indoor air quality in
public school buildings so those are
changed I think those changes come
directly from what we had discussed
previously uh
uh yes who made the second I just wanted
to see if sorry repres represent I think
for Ford representative Ford did you
have anything to add as the second or
other
motion um no okay represent Woodcock
thank you sure represent L on um 20 22
and 28 Rick the the reference to 2016
2017 on the front
page yeah is that is that
accurate that's when it
started okay
um that stuff's probably pass probably
could get knocked out but it's it's what
we had in the bill initially when we put
the infrastructure group together um so
I follow so yes I agree with youi but if
this if this passes like that is that
going to then cease uh terminate the
bill when it gets there they're going to
say it's that budget's gone
by you know what I mean all right yeah
that's you know that's current statute I
believe so it hasn't been current
statute it hasn't been a problem since
2017 we appropriated 10 million this
year before that we had money it's
almost like theame
moved thank
you um further comments questions
uh seeing
none um Madam
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yeah 15
minutes
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative mcdonal yes
representative Noble yes representative
peternell yes representative corello yes
repres
Miler representative Cornell
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna representative Heath yes
representative wock representative Hall
yes representative baloni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad 20 a
Zer that was 20 to zero well that's the
on the amendment yeah on the amendment
is that I just wanted to get the correct
yeah thank
you um I'd like to make a motion the for
the bill 1165 OTP
a second by represent Damon further
discussion on
otpa see none um Madam clerk when you're
ready yes oh I'm sorry representative
Ford okay um yeah thank you very
much I have represent
yeah okay first right so um we're all
ready for the roll call when you are
Madam clerk uh Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler representative
Cornell yes representative tenner yes
representative luno representative Heath
yes representative wood yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 a here
a consent
okay okay we're rushing because we have
something that got to get out of here in
a few minutes uh for testifying
elsewhere next bill we're going to do is
1570 it is an early bill
and there is an amendment for
it
control
okay this is House Bill
1570 relative to the administration of
school building and a funds by the
Department of Education and making it
appropriation therefore and coming
around is amendment
0336 like to make a motion yeah uh call
on um uh chairman lad for a motion I'd
like to recommend OTP on
1570 second second second by
representative Miler uh
comment yes I'd like to recommend
41570 Amendment
H as an amendment to the
bill second to the amendment represent
Miler okay I'd like to explain this
because it's coming at everybody pretty
quickly
as you may recall the bill 1570 it's an
early bill but if you can remember that
this
bill put in $70 million into the educ
from the education trust fund into a
school building Aid fund within that
fund and there is also stipulations of
how future monies would be put in a
certain percentage of the Surplus
80% which is huge amount and there was a
percentage set aside for
administration and when I looked at it
really carefully there were a lot of
areas that was just not it's it's it's a
good idea but it's not ready but at the
latter part of this bill there is a
portion of the bill which we have talked
about for years and that is doing a
survey of the schools which are out in
the state in terms of
that we can put the 10-year plan that we
encourage districts to do to really be
able to do it based upon prioritization
and have folks that are coming out a
contracted service that would come out
or a person a group that a vendor to
conduct a facility assessment of all the
schools or the schools which we need to
do it on and that would be done by the
same criteria for all schools not
necessarily the custodian or the
maintenance person doing that assessment
and sending that report into doe what
that's going to do it's going to better
provide us an awareness of what we have
to appropriate for uh building Aid in
many cases it's um also going to help
schools out uh in terms of knowing what
they're dealing with um we've also been
told that that the cost we have 33
million square ft of facilities in the
state and it was C somewhere between 5
cents and 10 cents or 15 cents per
square foot taking 10 cents if you take
the 33 million it's about square feet is
$3.3 million I think that's my math
right um and that's what would have to
be appropriated for this um it's
something that we have tried to do I
know that there's um uh a certain
representative from Bo that tried this
I've tried this numerous people on both
sides have tried to get this done so we
can more accurately know what's out
there and so we can project and and and
project uh budgets that reflect need so
what I've done I've I've I've left in
exactly the wording which was in that
bill with Part B there which is in bold
that was in the bill everything in part
A was already in the ball rule stat it's
already statute so what we're doing is
just looking at that last part there's
one two three four five lines which
would be added to this thank you
uh further comment yeah I I would just
uh reiterate what uh chairman lad said
that we've been waiting for a long time
to do this kind of an assessment we've
talked about it for several years so uh
this would basically put this into
operation thank
you any other committee
members representative
lakas okay so it says all after the
enacting Clause so we're getting rid of
the bill Aid fund created and
invested and all of that that correct
that's correct okay and then my other
question is in the original bill it had
how the Contracting cost were to be paid
it's not in
here is that intentional as well it's
intentional see the State Board of
Education shall adopt Rules pursuant to
This paragraph above and I'll figure it
as that that's exactly right okay thank
you
yeah any further comments from the
committee uh representative Heath um
question for you Mr chair um why
couldn't we consider the education trust
for
this um repres yeah um I don't see why
we couldn't um well for the whole whole
program itself we're going to take seven
$7 million from that trust to invest
then every year thereafter
80% of uh was it the Surplus I'd have to
look at that bill I don't have that bill
in front of me you know the first part
the education trust there was a certain
percentage that that went for
administration of the program as well
and the I like the concept but I I don't
like the if we were going to do anything
if we didn't do this I would have been
recommending interim study for the whole
bill
uh forther yeah thank
you further comment
questions seen none Madam clerk um this
is the amendment
0336 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 28
Zer further motion yes thank you Mr
chair I recommend
otpa on HB 570 with 0336 H as the
amendment sir second by representative
Miler uh discussion no further
discussion okay any comments from the
committee seeing none U Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes represent resentative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 a z
aent yes
great we've just now completed all the
early bills we had in the docket for
today that we wanted to
do so congratulations the
way okay next you got to go next
door
okay yeah 1088 1088 okay we'll try that
one the the up pens yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
1088 okay enabling schools to maintain
epinephrine Auto injectors is the title
of the bill it's
1088 and I Look to represent dry for a
motion yeah I would make a motion of
ought to pass I'd like to second that
motion so Madam clerk we have a motion
made by represent dry and second by
Tanner
OTP represent dry yes just want to say
that we did a lot of research on this
bill um it we look to cover all the
aspects that uh people hire up the chain
we're talking about including training
storage of pens um and dosage and found
that all of those concerns were already
addressed in the um different sections
of the chapter that we're including this
into so that um basically we've met
everyone's concerns it's already a
practice that's going around around the
state and we think it's a great
idea further discussion from the second
yeah yes I think this is such a um
important bill because it's a
life-saving bill uh that has to have you
know can have immediate effects on on
someone uh with an allergic reaction and
as as representative dry said we've
we've contacted all the stakeholders and
we feel very confident that this is a
good bill to go
forward okay is there F further
discussion on this
bill
a lot of hands up okay so no hands are
up so with that Madame clerk would you
please call the rooll vice chairman
cordelli he's not here oh I'm sorry
okay um representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative tenner yes
representative luno representative uh
Heath
yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Alon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes so that's 19 y one absent we're all
good with consent yes thank
you
okay we'll go to HB
who else has to go somewhere this
afternoon for hearings repr B are you
going to be going right now or about
minutes okay 1436 I recognize represent
beler I would like to make a motion to
itl
1436 is there a
second representative Cornell
made the second to itl
1436 represent
Bela yes thank you uh just one moment so
I can see what exactly am I telling
here
Bill oh yes excellent um so I I'm making
this motion on my own bill because after
Consulting and doing research I have
found that the demand for an uptime of
$99 % on a website uh is likely outside
of the University's control and is not a
recognized industry standard um I'm
deadly serious about reform but I'm also
deadly serious about bringing a bill
that I believe Will Survive a court
challenge if it so happens and as
written right now I don't think this
bill is workable or would survive a
court challenge so I move
it from the
second okay further discussion from the
committee not seeing any uh represent
cello when you're ready representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 Y and one
absent who made the second on that
one now P
okay any objections to consent was one
he good we're good then
on
here
look at
that I was looking at that for to see if
uh represent Celli had something to do
with
that
yeah I believe he has an amendment on
that does he yes he
does that's Deb hopson's
Bill okay so but there is an amendment
coming um I think it deals with one of
those steps of
removing was the
U the neutral conference yeah
yeah but I don't have that m in front of
me and I think he'd want to present that
and deal with it
then par
me I'm trying to find
it last
year this is which
one yeah just trying to find my sheet
here you told me
there okay that was oh I remember that
was on the second
page it's not one that we had down dos
right now let's get in a little bit
um
1555 okay let's go with
1555 this is relative to special
meetings for changes in education
funding sponsor was representative
fellows 155 5 and I Look to represent
Pell for a motion thank you I move ought
to pass on House Bill
1555 is there a
second okay represent Ford second
that uh represent pel made the motion of
OTP and representative pel would you
like to speak to your
motion yes thank you um this is a a
technical change uh from the Department
of
Education and this bill as modifies the
special district meeting process when
changes in adequacy are made after the
District budget budgets have already
been adopted the special district
process allows for a District budget to
be changed outside of the annual
District meeting the only thing um
what's being revised is how the
districts calculate their Max warrant
article amount and chain that's that's
what the bill does
that's that's oh okay that's it that's
it is there any more discussion on the
bill not seeing any further
discussion Madam clerk H clerk would you
call the role
please representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
eler oh he's not here um representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
peternell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler I think I'm voting
no representative Cornell no
no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
baboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
so that is eight yays 10 Nays two
absent how
many
M
okay thank you very much so it's uh 10
to8
8 to oh it's 8 to 10 yes
so is there a
motion yeah I'll move I'll move
itl is there a
second
yes
is there any question I am not going to
go through with the vote on this until
everybody's back in their chair too on
this one so we can have discussion right
now on it any further discussion on why
the
itl sure um thank you Mr chair so
looking at the the um the bill only has
a few lines in it but it does add to a
um
a sometimes use section of law where
school boards May seek to hold a special
meeting uh for changes in school funding
and there's a lot of um uh situations I
think that can that can trip into this
like um like if a if a if on the floor
of a school meeting it increases the
authorization beyond what a budget
committee does by 10% I think that may
be one of these conditions but this is a
new condition that's being added and and
honestly it's not clear because it looks
like the difference between the the
October Grant estimate and the final
Grant estimate
um and and I think we need to we need to
make sure we know exactly what we're
getting ourselves into when um when
requiring a a school board to uh to have
to um uh seek an order for a special
meeting would it not be better then that
we were go looking at inter room study
to ascertain whether this is you know
how it would take place and how it be
done I'd be okay with
that so would uh you be willing to take
back the itl I would I would pull back
my um my itl motion and replace and and
put the inter study and replace that
with an interim study
okay so we had we're the other motions
were eliminated we're going with
represent
luno and represent Miler was the second
was you for in room
study is our further discussion the
motion the floor is in room
study I think that's much better
yes okay Madam
clerk representative
yes representative Ford yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna representative Heath
yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbone yes representative cascan yes
representative Damon yes chairman Le yes
18 Y and two
absent yeah that can go consent there's
no objections with that and I I think
it's wise we pulled back on that to go
to the house and have a 1010 on that
issue doesn't do
it yeah no it wouldn't be healthy um
used to have an award in school we gave
out every month and there was that out
the lunch aard and we had a lunch box
which we passed around we would have
gotten the out the lunch award on that
bill if we'd gone the other way I'm sure
was there much testimony on that bill I
wasn't here that Day represent fellows
came
in and for
something yeah
yeah okay
um now how about we take about a five or
10 minute break right now
yeah so we're going to take a 10-minute
break I got to catch up I I need to
write down so we can get that in the
over here what we accomplished before we
get to buried so in the order what we
did this
afternoon so it's in sending order so
that was the last
one okay let me put okay the first one
is uh where's the bill number
1555 okay good yeah okay then we 1436
yeah yeah
okay
yeah
but as as a reminder if you made a
motion you know like the primary motion
and and if you were a minority we have
to have the blurbs done right
off um so if if we have a break here I
would suggest that some of you start
working on that um because we can't we
can't wait and wait and wait because
we're going to be piling a whole lot of
new bills on tomorrow too and it's just
going to start compiling it's hard to
keep track and that is something that
every committee is being asked to do is
get the committee reports done on the
day before you
leave so something you might be wanting
to think
about
session yeah we're probably going to
have a subcommittee working on the two
College Bills or the due process we
haven't set it up yet that was going to
go in or no we can't do it because no
that's this Thursday no so no on
Thursday we won't have
anything I always
forget yeah want autopilot you know so
I'll be working on things tonight for
scheduling for the next week y yep
yep on consent is that a majority
report if it's on consent there's on
it's a committee report yeah see I don't
like that form yeah because there's all
kinds of technical stuff that's wrong
with it too you you go to type down here
and the lines keep going down and you
they are writing okay Long Easy except
for C's fine yeah that's what they're
going get the other one that I did um
Miler did went to arm study and it was
20 to zero was the final thing so he
writes that's exactly right and I don't
have to do anything because it was 20
nothing it was 20 nothing yet there's
only one report that's the committee
report which now we'll do because it's
in our own study got it okay thank you
y control
We Will We
[Music]
Will
okay okay I'm just going to go load up a
little water here and I'll be
right
that's 1066
and Har
me yeah but we can we can put it forward
and then we're not going to take any
action right
exactly okay we're at HB
1066 I can find
it okay this is relative to the
graduation requirement of filing a free
application for federal student aid
called FAFSA and with that I'd like to
recognize representa Noble
I move a to pass on HB
1066 like second so we have a motion
made by representative Noble OTP and
second by representative
Damon yeah I don't I
don't
right
okay uh representative Noble you're
recognized thank you Mr chair um I know
that the current law is important to
some of us but in practice I think that
the Schoolboard policy makes a lot more
sense for our districts and for
parents um like I said in the hearing I
had at least in my district um parents
were
very United um behind this bill which is
super unusual in these times
um the nhsaa supports this bill the nhba
supports this bill and I hope you all
will as
well that's it representative
Damon I am supporting this bill uh
because the superintendent in my
district found it challenging to follow
through with and requested this to
happen yes there any further discussion
from members of the committee represent
Miler thank you Mr chair I understand
the some we just have started this
program and I understand from the
feedback that we've gotten that it has
been difficult for some school
districts to get the information from
students but I don't want us to forget
the original intent of this
bill the original intent of this bill
was to have students fill out the FY
form and as a result of that begin to
recognize that perhaps those who didn't
think they could go to college or go to
further their education either in
college or community colleges or in a a
skill trade
program and that was the intent of it I
mean we didn't I don't think the
original intent was to provide an
onerous experience for parents Etc and
so I'm going to be voting against the
OTP um
not in non- recognizing the problems but
in the spirit of the originally bill as
it was passed thank you further
discussion representative
Ford I admit that the original intent
was it just
described but I would also say that what
the bill is now addressing is the need
for all students to assess the financial
ability of continuing their education
it's now being required for programs of
studies in the industrial
Arts Plumbing Heating all those kinds of
things there are uh programs affiliated
with institutions that require the FAFSA
you cannot apply from for some state aid
without fulfilling this FAFSA and so
they don't
even they can't say it's just for
college it's not just for college it's
for the craft for the Arts for a lot of
things and so a student doesn't have any
real comprehension of what they're going
to need if they choose to pursue
additional study After High
School and I think that's what the fafta
does it lets them understand how you can
do it who's going to fund it and there
are lots of different sources of funding
I was astounded quite frankly when I
would began exploring this and there's a
lot of money out there for people who
want to pursue things other than College
so I would be in favor of this
bill further discussion on the bill
representative Tanner thank you and I
totally agree with everything
representative Ford has has mentioned um
I too am concerned uh that you know that
students don't always understand the
total Financial packages that may be out
there for them and that many of them
just kind of right off College I you
know when you talk to them uh and fapa
filling out a fapa form
helps I on the other hand I will be
voting for this bill because I've also
talked to school administrators who feel
that that the barrier of graduation for
not filling out the form and the fact
that it puts pressure on some students
whose parents really do not want to fill
out a Federal Form um make it very
difficult and when the end of the school
year comes and people are running around
trying to get graduation together and
who gradu grates and who doesn't and and
all that I I don't think the filling out
the FAFSA form should be a check off on
that list thank you is there further
discussion
on on the
bill yes representative luno very
quickly thank you Mr chair so um so Mr
chair you and I serve on the um the the
governor's higher education or ccsnh and
usnh task force and so uh so College um
College Bound uh students is something
that is very interesting to what the
what the task force is doing I um I'm
I'm going to vote against the um the the
ought to pass but uh but but I think the
the bill that's being presented here
while it does eliminate the um the faf
as a require as a graduation requirement
has a good spirit um to it that that I
think in general improves the the
financial literacy of of um of of high
school students and gives them a better
understanding of what of how they can
afford College than maybe they had in
the past but but really I just want to
sort of leave everybody with uh one of
the things that came up at the task
force meeting on Friday last week which
was a report prepared by the Department
of Education I'll see if I can find it
and uh and send it out that um that
shows the percentage of students in
every High School that are going on to
four-year colleges 2-year colleges um uh
uh the workplace um uh armed services uh
or other and um and it's um it's not at
all even close to uniform in terms of uh
in terms of the opportunities that um
that that students are choosing you're
seeing some high schools will um you
know uh uh
you and I I don't remember the number
off the top of my head but maybe 15 % of
the graduating class might be might be
going off to a to higher education
through a two or fouryear college well
well in other high schools it's closer
to
90% and um and there's certainly I think
a lot of work that that we can be doing
and I hope the task force will do and
having a better understanding as to why
students are making these decisions
because they're um there're it's it's
it's not at all that that 60% of the
kids are going off to college
uh it's it it fluctuates wildly and I
hope that's something that as a
legislative body uh we can get a better
better understanding of what those
causes are making sure these kids have
successful livelihoods down the road
thank
you and as a member of that same group
and as a member of the trustees um we
have discussed fa so quite often and we
have like the Bia will come in and talk
about it and others as well but we do
know that a lot of the uh C some of the
cost is for seeing uh this varying
number from percentages from one school
to another have a lot to do with uh the
stability of the community in terms of
wages and and and uh the ability the a
student looks at that and of course the
parents working there too and the
student knows I've got to go work at
Walmart I got to go work at Dunkin
Donuts because this is I need to help
bring some money into this family all
also due to the nature of families
there's a lot more divorce and all out
there now and the single family is
trying to make it uh so it's putting
pressure on on students and I think it's
also important that the FAA FAFSA be
communicated with kids not as a
graduation requirement but so they
understand there are ways I can get
there there's ways I can get the grant
money for example from Plymouth State
and Kean and new in UNH there are
programs Grant Awards available for
those students which are cannot afford
it and many of those students come
without paying tuition at all if you
actually saw the net costs coming out
rather than what you're we always look
at and say oh we're the highest or the
second highest in the country but when
you take this bracket right here we're
not and so I you know I I think the fafs
is extremely important but we don't need
it as a graduation
requirement represent
Noble when you fill that form out you
have to list at least one school that
you want to send your information to so
you have already done the research you
already know that you want to go to
college at that point so it's not like
everybody just fill the form out and see
who can afford it you you already have
that desire to go to college or whatever
if if it's a a technical program that
works with FAFSA so you already you
already know what you're
doing um in my district they've talked
about
um adding this to the personal finance
class so that it does get more exposure
on top of the information nights that
they already do so just just another
thought forther yes represent
bony thank you um I just have one
question I'm not objecting to the repeal
of the form itself but I'm just con I
was just wondering why at the bottom
where you also repeal RSA 193 E3 which
is relative to reports on completing the
form and when I looked that up it just
is asking uh that the high school or the
schools submit the number and percentage
of graduating high school students
provided inperson School assistance in
completing a free application for
federal student aid that for doing that
form which is a voluntary thing so I'm
just questioning why you wouldn't want
to report
that
do anybody want to ask that question I I
I think that was just part of the law um
and yeah I I don't I don't see the
reason in keeping that there if we're
going to repeal the law
itself um my question is though uh don't
high schools voluntarily provide
assistance anyway um they're not
required to but I think this um is just
trying to get uh data on how many how
how how many students they actually help
complete the form that's
all we do have an indicator with
inadequacy an indicator that we are
delivering an adequate education that
requires schools to submit the the kids
which are going off to to the military
fafs and taking that that test those
which are going over off to higher
education yes that's part of one of the
indicators as well so doe does receive
this
information as a result of the
indicators were required to file as a
school district
annually correct me if I'm wrong
Representative
cascad no comment
okay
yeah okay further further discussion on
the
bill okay Madam clerk would you please
call the roll the the the recommendation
is OTP on HB
1066 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes no representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
there's a number there representative
Cornell
yes representative Tanner yes
Representative luno
no representative Heath
no representative wock yes
representative Hall
yes representative Bon do this
no representative
cascaden
yes representative Damon yes
yes and chairman lad yes 16 y four
n
i it's okay because I've never done I've
always done 173
182 no Minority Report okay yeah yeah so
it's
consent I I think it has to be regular
if it's four I I've never done it before
when there's been four opposed represent
have you heard of
it I
yeah just just put it on and don't have
a Minority Report on it and then
everybody will get that clue on the
house floor right yeah are you are you
okay with that mayor no Minority
Report okay there's a yes no for
minority rep representative
Woodcock I understand that historically
it's been three or two one 2011 but if
the committee agrees to put on consent
that's what they should
do well let's give it a shot and then
see what happens you know I move
consent good so it's not like an
automatic thing if it was an automatic
thing they wouldn't have a thing a check
to box right
well just check it anyways so yes okay
yes thank you very
much no no no no no no no because he'll
tell you no
[Laughter]
all right
just
uh thank you Mr chair um I would like to
move out to pass is there a
second second
and I have an
amendment okay represent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman um uh I
have an amendment uh to uh bring forward
that I would like uh to move out to pass
on it is U Amendment
H do everybody have a copy of that get
there getting
there
it's not three
punched yes I'll speak to
it are there any extras going around
that
side of the
amendment
all set the side okay
it's
17 okay we have a Amendment yes it was
seconded by representative beler right
did you second the amendment or just the
bill
OTP pardon
me
okay okay uh thank you Mr chairman um
during testimony
um the other day on um neutral
conferences um we heard testimony from a
couple of people um most importantly the
special ed Advocate who went through a
quite um detailed uh description of the
uh process that parents are faced with
with uh pursuing uh due process on a
special education case um this is um
occurring after uh the IEP and there are
there is a dispute about the services um
uh being offered uh and the two
different tracks that a parent can get
involved in um on and on the one track
on um the one side you have neutral
conferences
mediation um on the other side you have
um uh I forget all the steps but due
process hearings itself is over on the
other side so
um I think from testimony we've heard
over the past several years and
unfortunately uh some of the freshmen
have missed some very uh uh important
testimony over the past couple of terms
from specialed parents uh trying to
navigate through the
process um and coming up on
um the process and um trying to make it
through the process I I remember a a
lawyer with a special needs child
talking about how long she had to study
specialed law to try and figure out what
she had to do to get services for her
child um we heard the special ed
Advocate talk about um the um
unprocessed uh disputes that she was
involved in trying to find a solution um
and these were long-term disputes that
hadn't been settled and who was
suffering but the child because the
child was not getting the services that
the parent thought were was needed and
she s has been successful in and getting
a number of those resolved
thankfully um so after the
hearing I went back to the department
and that one sheet you have a double
side or two-page sheet is the uh uh
dispute resolutions and and um uh
indications of uh settlement
Etc but um Steven Berwick who is the ad
administrator for dispute resolution and
complaints indicated to me that since
July
2021 there has been one neutral
conference
one in three
years um is this something that we have
to put in parents is this another step
um that we have to tell parents that
they have to look into or if they want
to take that track can't they go just
straight to
mediation
um I think we can simplify the process
and that's what the special ad Advocate
was talking about was simplifying the
process um and this uh I hope is one
small step in simplifying the
process um because it's um a gauntlet
that uh parents have to go through
um to get services and I I know of
current parents who are uh I know of one
parent who has been struggling for three
years to get services for their
child
and they're they're trying to make a
decision right now they have the
resources they can go out and get the
services on a private basis or should
they stay and fight because it impacts
other kids too and right now now they're
continuing to stay in fight for the
services they think are needed for their
child we have to do better um and we
heard that from the special edit
advocate so I I think it's a a matter of
simplification it's a matter of just as
a first step you know we heard also
about um the manuals and the guidance
that's available um you know manuals
this thick for parents to try and figure
out how do they get through the
process um is that right um can't we
simplify things for the for the parent
but also um there's
um well I I I won't go into that right
now but um that's the reason that I am
um putting forward um this amendment and
uh uh I I think it is um a small step
but a needed step thank
you thank you simply because it is a
complex issue and I'm not sure what the
real answer and um representative
Cordell I appreciate your diligence to
this could I ask um um our our
specialist over here if she would come
forward from the Hampshire school boards
Association and just explain the impact
of what this amendment would do I just
don't want to do I don't want to vote
for anything that I might be taking
something away from appearance
options would it be
okay that would be great yes yeah but
she did special
it I don't know that's
what thank you Mr CH good afternoon for
the record I'm Becky Wilson uh director
of governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school board
Association uh previously known as a
special ed
director Becky do have you seen the
amendment I've not seen the amendment
but I'm sure someone can just read it to
me I will read it to you quickly okay
you're G I just don't
understand would this be a an option
taken away from parents in the multitude
of things that are
available I guess thank you for the
question I guess I would defer that to
representative cordelli since he's
brought forth uh this amendment it would
appear to me that's just removing
neutral conference as an option is that
correct thank you um
so it's it's difficult I listened to the
testimony on this bill originally and on
the discussion about the neutral
conference um and I was just sort of
trying to put down some notes a little
bit while I was listening to you all
talk I think and again I'm not speaking
on behalf of the office of the special
ed Advocate or any of the complaints
that have been heard at the department
level or anything to that effect in the
past dispute resolution was to some
extent a ladder it was not to parallel
processes as it feels like it's been
perceived most
recently um if you had a dispute as an
IEP team you would have the option for
example to have your IEP meeting
facilitated which I think was discussed
at at length last time I will tell you
that in 2018 I requested an IEP
facilitation from the department and uh
the director of special ed at the time
Becky fet said she would be happy to
come facilitate my meeting but she was
the only person trained to do it at the
time and as a district it would be
difficult for my staff to have the
office of the special education director
of the state facilitating your IEP
meeting so that would option while it
was probably the most important and most
appropriate wasn't really available and
that was to know nobody's fault it was
just the situation at hand at the
department which you spoke about earlier
was underst staffed and had no IEP
facilitator um neutral conference for a
very long time was purported to be a
situation where if you had a um case
that had gone through mediation and
could not be resolved had gone through
facilitation and could not be resolved
that in order to save both parties some
angst and to try to preserve your
relationship as an IEP team you would go
to a neutral conference to present your
case as if you were going to a due
process hearing and the hearing officer
would tell you generally how they
thought they might rule on the case were
it to go to doe process it was meant to
try
to alleviate some of the concerns that I
hear coming from this committee
currently which is that people would
have to fight and fight and fight and go
through this massive due process hearing
only to find out maybe that they hadn't
really thought through what the
consequences could be or what the
outcome would be Etc it was meant to
preserve um the team's ability to make a
decision at that point about whether or
not they wanted to go forward with due
process it sounds to me based off of
what the office of the special ed
Advocate is portraying that it's maybe
turned into some other kind of process
um however I do know you know the office
of the special ed Advocate I think the
entire role of that person is to hear
problems so all they're going to hear is
problems they're not I don't know if
neutral conference has been used in a
different way with other cases um so if
you were to remove
that my my two cents from that would be
that if you had gone to facilitation and
or mediation and needed to go to doe
process teams would no longer have the
option to sort of vet out their case
before going through a due process
hearing and if you have ever been
through a due process hearing say in 21
years I went to Due Process two times
everything else I probably went to
mediation maybe 10 times total and there
it's important to recall that in some
situations a district has to get
resolution on a special education
decision and the district has to file
for mediation or due process it's not
always the parent that is pushing that
there are resolutions that have to
happen legally and a district can't just
sit on decisions because you wouldn't be
fulfilling your obligation to students
so if you were to remove neutral
conference from the option it sounds to
me as though you would maybe do IEP
facilitation possibly there's two people
in the state that can do that right now
you might go to mediation if you felt
like it was something that you could
resolve through mediation but there are
some situations as with any Ed or not
related that would go to mediation where
sometimes you know there's no resolve
coming from that process that you would
no longer have the option to sort of
think about a neutral conference as an
option you would just have to go right
to a due process
hearing I'm sorry just a quick followup
so it sounds like the preparation for
due process might happen a little bit in
that neutral setting thank you yes
that's correct I mean you you are I
don't want to call it a mock hearing
it's not it it carries much more
emotional and otherwise weight than a
mock hearing um but yeah you're
preparing your cases on both sides
to try to see if it is worth it quite
honestly because it it takes a toll on
people as you've heard in this committee
financially but also emotionally if
you're going to a neutral conference or
a due process hearing on a case where
the child is Young For example the
district test and maintain a
relationship with that family for a very
long time after this situation and you
have many more IEPs yet to come you
don't want to go to Due
Process over something that maybe is not
going to result in an ability to move
forward for the many years after
that uh thank you um just to add to that
so there are two I think I explained
this the other day you can correct me if
I'm wrong there is an informal process
for alternative dispute resolution and
there's an informal the informal
generally has someone who knows special
education has experience in it to try to
mediate the situation if we repeal this
bill this takes away some autonomy for a
parent or a school district to go to the
formal level of dispute resolution
because then instead of the neutral
person being the specialist in special
ed or the practitioner you have an
attorney who knows special ed laws so
they can advise the team prior to taking
this to due process and maybe it would
be resolved in that fashion but there
are two separate different means of
dispute uh dispute
resolution um and they're both um they
each have their specialist on board
which gives another option to parents so
I don't know why we would want to take
away an opportunity for parents I so I
think it should
OTP thank you Mr chair and Miss
Wilson I I'm
I need I need some help here I may need
help a lot of help over but anyway on
this I was totally confused when the
parent advocate got through going like
this and all this so if you could for me
finally go through the steps okay so I
have an IEP with my
child and I agree with the IEP all right
simple set that aside I disagree with
the
IEP can you tell me what happens next
what are my Alternatives and I'm
particularly concerned with what
representative cascaden said as far as I
want to provide as many options without
confusing
parents for what their options are so if
you could kind of I'm in dispute now
what what are the steps that I go
through and how that how's that all work
okay thank you for the question I will
do my best to be sustin in this and I'm
going to work from the position that
perhaps your child has already had an
IEP for some time and that because if it
is an initial IP that is a
separate a separate discussion because
there are some parental consent
requirements that are different for the
very first time a child is identified
versus moving forward so assuming your
child's been identified and they've
already had an IEP and now the IEP is
due for the annual review you get
through the IEP process you get I'll use
an assumption What I Hear often in this
committee to the service delivery page
and there's a there's a um disagreement
about how many services what services
how long the services are
Etc there is a provision in special
education called stay put which
basically means that the team must
operate based on the last agreed upon
IEP until the dispute is resolved so
whatever was agreed upon in the last IEP
where the entire team agreed which is
the parents included that continues to
happen there's no just cut off of the
child services while you figure out
what's happening next whatever was
happening previously continues to happen
it's also not uncommon that if for
example the child's getting three or
four services on that page and the
parent agrees with three out of the four
that you would agree as a team and this
is all written up in agreement with the
parent that you would provide the new
services for those three that everyone
agrees on and you would just continue to
figure out what to do with this fourth
service if you cannot come to an
agreement and the team can continue to
meet and have as many meetings as the
parent and the team are willing to do
together to try to resolve it if you get
to a point where you can't resolve it
most often the next step would be
mediation that's most common IEP
facilitation would be an option but
again if you aren't really having a
problem creating the IEP it's you
realize you get to a point where there's
sort of this you know unfixable moment
you would go to mediation and the goal
of that is to preserve your relationship
as a team so that you can do this again
next year when you have an IEP without
having to go to mediation you would go
to mediation it mediation looks
different for every team sometimes
everyone's in the same room sometimes
it's much more what you would picture
from a family court situation with
mediation where some people are in one
room once in the other people go back
and forth the med Creator's job is to
try to resolve in the best interest of
both parties whatever the issue is if
that does not work the parent and the
team whoever's G put this process in
place in the first place has a decision
you can agree to go either way so agree
with what the parent is saying and amend
the IEP for that issue or not and if not
then you have to resolve it you can't
just leave this
issue out to dry um you would have to go
to a due process hearing um or the
parent would have to pursue a due
process hearing if they felt that it was
something they really wanted to go
through for this
issue but the old IEP is still happening
all this time that you that the adults
are doing all of this stuff over here
the student is still getting the last
agreed upon services so so just if I may
so where does the facilitated
conversation take place in the process
you just
outlined in theory before you would ever
go to mediation where the team has been
trying to resolve this issue and they
say you know what it's too emotional
everyone is too in mesed at this point
we need someone to come in and run this
meeting for us to focus on the issue and
see if they can pick up on something
that we're not picking up on and come to
resolution thank you for that
clarification you're
welcome thank you Mr chair and thank
you at what point in all this process if
any does the state director of special
education become involved thank you for
the
question
typically the department is only getting
involved if there is a complaint which
is different than not agreeing on an i
that's a process that is totally
separate from making a department of Ed
complaint even even then the director of
special ed themselves would not
necessarily be the person taking the
complaint I think it was said earlier
right now that's Steven Berwick
um they re they really would not ever be
involved as a role specifically the
reason that Miss fet would have been
involved in the past might have been
because she was the only person that was
trained and qualified to provide the IEP
facilitation so if you ask for that if
you put in a request for that to the
department and she is the only person
that's qualified to provide that service
at that time she might have become
involved thank
you thank you um mentioned facilitated
IEPs am I correct in that the um the
process begins with the IEP if there is
no agreement they could move to a
facilitated
IEP and if there's still no um agreement
then you would take a different path
such as mediation or something else is
that correct thank you for the question
yes although I personally I would
consider it all one PA it's one path you
have a dispute that you are trying to
resolve it's dispute resolution
regardless of what method you take um
it's just there are certain timelines
and things like that that are embedded
in each step so that you don't put any
team in a position where this dispute is
going on for years at a time you have
certain timelines that you have to abide
by so that in the child's best interest
and in the team's best interest you're
not just letting things hang out there
for months on
end so then the
neutral would come after the um
potentially after the mediation if that
still didn't work but before you
actually go to court you would do this
to get an idea of how that might happen
and at that point you might realize this
is not going to work anyways I withdraw
or you might say oh I need this
additional information to bring with me
when I go and that kind of stuff thank
you for the question yes just I you also
might learn in neutral conference that
perhaps it's not going to go the way
either side thinks it's going to go and
so you might be willing to go back to
mediation mediation is not mandatory in
this ladder of dispute resolution it's
optional and both parties have to agree
to go to mediation so so if the district
or the parent says you know what this
isn't something we we've been trying to
work this out for x amount of time
mediation is just going to further harm
our relationship with this family they
might not go they might just say you
know listen we need to get a result on
this but yes neutral conference would
then allow people to sort of have an
idea of what they were getting
themselves into for lack of a better
term thank you Mr chair and thank
you so if I'm
understanding this correctly neutral
conference is to prevent the need to
have a due process hearing is that
because it's less costly and maybe less
of an emotional toll or is that a
correct summarization of it thank you
for the question representative I don't
want to ascribe what people would get
out of neutral conference to having up
in every situation is very
individualized as is special education
as a whole um I think the intent
originally and again the office of the
special ed
Advocate explained some things in a way
that is based off of her perception of
how things are going and I know that's a
very new position so I don't want to
misspeak in terms of how she presented
those things on her hand I will tell you
that when we went to neutral conference
if ever you were to go it was to try
to get to a point where everybody could
could see that things were just going to
become more difficult by to go down this
very litigious Road as opposed to trying
to be more open to going back to trying
to resolve it in a much more
collaborative manner thank
you afternoon I'm sure glad you came in
today just the question would it be fair
to say then U not the original bill but
on the amendment that this is the appeal
based on the amendment would actually um
limit a parents opportunity and probably
negate something the two of
walks thank you for the question I don't
again I don't want
to um try to guess at what the
Department's intention was or what the
original intention was in terms of this
bill I I will say yeah if you take it
away it's no longer an option thank you
thank you
chairman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here um this is really
helpful this list here but um there
weren't very many neutral conferences in
the last 10 years compared to other
things like mediation and of the ones
that there were
only three were settled in the neutral
conference so having that option there
is that maintaining a cost that's not
used very much or is it just something
that people are otherwise occupied is it
a special group that we would lose or is
this something that's covered by the the
people that do the other things as well
thank thank you for the question I would
want you to confirm with the Department
who's currently acting as the hearing
officers for the neutral conferences in
the past it's this it's the same pool of
people so to speak that would be hearing
the due process case obviously not the
same person you wouldn't have the same
person hearing neutral conference and
then hearing the due process case but
it's the same pool of people I don't
know who's currently doing it I have not
gone to neutral conference in many many
years um so I don't know what the cost
that in terms of the department would be
um the cost in terms of fiscal costs at
the depart at the district level or at a
parent level if you're at the point
where you're going to neutral conference
you're have those costs regardless
probably because you're trying to
resolve something that needs to be
resolved thank you are there any
specific criteria for a person that is
coming
inated conference or mediation
[Music]
thank you for the question
um again I don't want I don't hire um
any of the people that are the leads in
those separate areas I will tell you I
believe the two current people in the
state that are providing IEP
facilitation are either uh retired
special education administrators so they
do have some level of special ed law
knowledge or at least the process or are
retired or add specialed Advocates that
tend to work with families that no
longer are doing that actively um you
know you certainly would need to have a
level of understanding of the IEP
process to be able to facilitate an IEP
meeting in the past um not so much
anymore but I believe the parent
information center and several other
organizations have provided IEP
facilitators to teams as part of a
parent partnership with school districts
across the state um they will come in
and help with that there's there are
other people besides the department that
in the past have offered that service
but it may have been because there was
just a lack of resource at the
department level so people were willing
to do those things uh the neutral
conference off and the due process
hearing officers to
my recollection are mainly attorneys
because it is an attorney based process
at that point when you go to a due
process hearing mediators are often
attorney although not
always you're
welcome so what I so see if I just want
to clarify what we have before us we
have the original Hobson
bill which basically provides some
clarification on the role of the neutral
that's one issue
the second issue is the cordellia
amendment which basically
repeals that option is that is that am I
clear in that
understanding me to be an expert on
this and and there's what's in law right
now and there's what's in law too so so
I just think as I just as I really
appreciate uh Miss Wilson's explanation
it's really clarified a lot for me after
being with this for 12 years but but
anyway so those are the two issues you
got the repeal versus the clarification
of the
alternative that's what's before us and
what's before us right now what's on the
floor is the repeal Amendment from
cordelli is that correct that's how I
see it okay thank you very much cordelli
uh thank you um a few things
um we just heard that the special ad
education Advocate um maybe has a
different view of things because she
works with parents who are having
problems well that's why we had an
advocate to begin with because of all
the problems we've heard about I well
I'm sorry that's
okay I'm sorry did I you no just I'm
talking to represent
Tanner um
so that's why we have the special eded
advocate because there were problems
after the study committee we had
um um we put into place a performance
audit on the
department um then Senator rean turned
to me and said let's do something
big so we drafted the special ed
Advocate
law um and that's right she hears from
parents who are having problems but
isn't that who we want to hear
from if everything's going along fine
then great Dandy we want to hear from
the parents and help the parents who are
having
problems um secondly um I also talked to
um an advocate who was trained in the
parent information center who agreed
that this is a meaningless step in the
process and as um representative dry
pointed out there have been seven
neutral conferences in 10
years seven and 10
years so you know if if
we get rid of the neutral controverses
we're not turning the special ed process
upside
down maybe we're simplifying it for
parents thank
you
thank you um no matter how often it's
been used it has been used and obviously
it has worked with a few but I'm just
going to say you want to take away a
choice from
parents thank you Mr chair and and I
believe it is a choice for parents
because there doesn't appear to be
anything in the um in the uh ADR statute
c23 that um that requires a neutral
conference to be held prior to mediation
I think um the parties could uh could
could could decide to do um um uh either
one of those things or maybe even both
of those things um to come to a
conclusion so I don't know why we'd want
to take um tools out of the
toolbox
not further discussion I was wondering
if we could call a
caucus
cordelan
yes Representative leus
no representative
Ford
no representative beler
yes representative dry
yes representative McDonald
no representative Noble
no representative
Pell
no representative corello yes
representative Miler
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno
no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
five y's 15
Nays
uh yes um obviously this is
U Frau with all kinds of questions
Etc and um I originally was I was
originally going to vote OTP on this but
I think I've changed my mind because I
think there are questions about why is
the change what is the change there's
confu as I said I was confused about
what the uh parent advoc had to say uh
Mr Wilson basically helped clarify at
least the process that was
important if if the OTP fails I would
put forth an interim study committee uh
motion thank you Mr chair
okay about
OTP I would withdraw my motion yes was
there a second who did the second would
you like
motion inter study yes I put forward a
motion to interim study Mr chair thank
you
second forther
discussion okay we have a motion of
interim study for
1443 mam clerk would you please call the
RO Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative elure yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes representative Coro yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
alone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 y zero
n thank
you okay how about the 1109 the Eating
Disorders
build
I make a motion Mr
chair
motion thank you I'd like to make a
motion of
itl I do and I I have nothing against
eating hotlines or eating disorder help
or anything like that I just know that
in the world that I live in with social
service agencies we are moving to a
three digigit number because it's easier
for people to remember 988 is the number
um at this point the average weight from
988 247 is 41 seconds and um you're met
by uh an operator who can triage
the subject that the person is calling
about the national disorder hotline
that's going proposed for this ID is
open 9 to 7 on weekdays and and they all
recommend calling 988 if it's after
hours so I'm just saying that I'm in
my line of thinking I would like to go
along with the trend in social service
agencies to go towards the 988 number
thank you Mr chair I would urge people
to vote against the itl noting that we
passed this bill last year with a
different entity this is a solid 20
year-old well well-respected
organization people with eating
disorders do not perceive themselves as
in a mental health crisis that would
lead them to call
988 it is critically important that we
help them especially teenagers who have
such a high incidence of Eating
Disorders to access care or
recommendations for
Care at the time that they are ready and
willing to
call uh thank you I just wanted to point
out that we received express mail this
afternoon from the National Alliance for
heating disorders um and they indicate
that uh they plan to expand their hours
till 900 p.m. sometime within this year
and eventually want to add hours on
weekends thank you Mr chair um a after
the bit of a the ble we had with a very
similar Bill last year regarding this I
decided to do a little bit more homework
on this one and on this
organization and I have to say that what
I found was um seemed a bit disturbing
so reviewing the blog and some of the
advice that's being given by the
organization in question it's clear that
they ascribe to um what would commonly
be known as the body positivity movement
they offer advice recommending that you
can be uh healthy at any size for people
who are severely over Beast they
recommend against dieting re
recommending instead that they learn to
love themselves exactly how they are are
um now certainly people have every right
to do so I don't think it would be very
consumable for us to direct somebody
however to a medical Source providing
that kind of
advice thank you Mr chair um so I voted
against the similar Bill last year I'm
voting against this one too for the same
reasons um and I I'm glad they're having
expanded hours planning for expanded
hours um unless it's a 24/7 line I I
think that it's lacking um and you know
in no way does this I'm sure you all
know this we it's has nothing to do with
how I feel like you know of course I
care with kids with eating disorders um
but also practically speaking let's see
I don't know an ID card is smaller than
this paperclip box there are many other
worthy causes where does it stop that's
why I think this thre digigit movement
is is a good one just for a practical
from a practical point of view
uh so um I will be supporting the
itl thank you Mr chair one of the things
that we did here in the
testimony was that a eaing disorder is
is a little
different um that some don't think that
they have a problem uh yet they may we
also discovered too that this particular
hotline does more than just deal with
those who may have the eating disorder
it provides information to those who may
have friends who have the problem or
parents who have the problem so it is it
is a
resource that goes beyond just a crisis
intervention kind of a thing and we also
discovered that that the 988 number that
was mentioned earlier that it
tries the phone calls that come in this
one deals specifically with issues
dealing with that this particular topic
so that's that's why I'm I'm going to
vote against the I because I do think
that this is something that will benefit
those who have issues and those who are
trying to support those who have issues
by calling this particular hotline thank
you thank you um I
guess my first point might be that this
this disease this disorder is a hidden
disorder for the most part uh students
go out of their way and know how to go
out of their way to hide it um hide the
disorder they have it's not a
crisis uh like suicide would be where
they have suicide ideation or
hallucinations and they need to get the
phone number or a friend notices that
somebody's cutting themselves and you
know it's getting pretty severe that's a
crisis um the eating disorder can be
very chronic it can last a lifetime and
it this this particular line and working
with eating disorders and I'm no expert
but there are experts in the field and
if positive body image is what is needed
to treat that particular person at that
particular time in their eating disorder
I as a Layman is I'm not in a position
to criticize or try to diagnose what
they're doing or triage what they're
doing um Eating Disorders are prolific
in middle school high school and even
down in elementary school and parents
don't know how to handle it teachers
don't know how to handle it um and like
I said the kids often hide it I've i'
over the years I taught I dealt with
several families and kids girls that
that had this problem um and probably
knew a bunch of other ones that had a
problem and and I didn't recognize it or
they didn't bring it to me um it was
going to the
professionals that made a difference
and particularly in school you know it
isn't obvious where to go for eating
disorders it's just like Matthew when he
first talked to us about it here's this
kid he's a boy so he probably you know
has The Stereotype that he doesn't have
a eating disorder although boys
obviously do and was just he was trying
to find some
information and he wanted to talk to
somebody that knew something about
eating
disorders um he wasn't in crisis he
wouldn't have called 988 and 988 is a
wonderful number for crisis calls just
like 911 or you know 511 for the road
issues that you need on some of these
morning drives in here but I I really
think
that you know the fact that the card is
small it people put numbers on them look
at our uh driver's license how much
information is crammed on the front and
the back of the driver's license that's
not I think that's a red herring issue
but the real issue is how can we help
these kids and what's going to make a
difference and what's going to save
lives and the quicker you get on this
stuff the quicker you address the
problem the better chances you have of
ever correcting it and I'll I'll tell
you again there's a person over my area
that walks every day that has to be in
her 60s late 50s 60s and has had Eating
Disorders her whole life and is so
crippled she's really
almost unrecognizable I mean just
unrecognizable and her bones are like so
fragile um and her body her upper torso
is really even distorted from the
osteoporosis that she has
so and she's dealing with it at that and
she probably made it there because she
had good medical care and and she had
intervention otherwise she wouldn't have
even made it that long but it's a it's a
terrible thing and we need to do
something about it and if we save one
kid if there's a Matthew Brown out there
somewhere today that looks at the cart
calls that any disorder number and
starts the process of getting
help to me it's worth it so um I can't
tell you how important it is to vote for
this
bill yeah I'm listening to these things
and I'm I'm thinking of it may be
something that might satisfy both of
them my concern with the eating disorder
hotline
is that is limited hours and I think
when somebody finally gets up the nerve
to call there should be a human being on
the other end but my concern with the
just 988 the way it is now is that
somebody who has an eating disorder
might not recognize that that's a number
for them so I'm wondering what if we
leave the 988 but label it differently
so that it includes eating disorder ERS
because they will that's part of what
they do is if it's an eating disorder
they send them to that they redirect
them to I think somebody had said to
that very place that that would go and
what does do you still have your
card I do not have those on me at the
moment oh do you remember what it said
what the 988 was labeled as I believe
it's the National Suicide Prevention
hotline so if if we expanded
that to something that would be more
inclusive since they do deal with more
than just suicide does that make
sense thank you Mr
chair first of all I appreciate
representative lakes's effort to find a
middle ground but I disagree with it
people with eating disorders experience
a great deal of
Shame they will seek out help when or
information when they are near the
bottom but they're not usually suicidal
it's suicide by slow deaths starvation
or very high incidents of heart attacks
in people who are bulimic and they are
often fatal that's not suicide per se
you wouldn't call 988 for
that early treatment works more
successfully and that's what this
Endeavors to help students
get
I would vigorously push back against a
person or persons
evaluating the perspective and
information provided by the National
Alliance for eating
disorders if those folks are not do not
have expertise in this
field as you all know I spent 40 years
in this
field body positivity Health at every
size self-love non- dieting are
fundamental premises of what works that
isn't the the same thing as saying what
you put in your body doesn't matter it's
not saying nutrition isn't important it
is but you have to get a person to a
place where they can trust themselves to
make decisions to eat to retain what
they
eat to learn what a reasonable
relationship with food is and in order
to do that they need to get help in a
way that
feels trustworthy to them
I would also reiterate I believe it was
representative Myer who noted the value
of the helpline to people besides the
person with the eating
disorder so I vigorously urge you to
defeat the IDE itl pass n OTP and let's
get this
done
thank you I know very much about this
this subject uh not because I really
wanted to have to learn about it
but people whove confront this
challenge
panic and then they go underground as
our colleague has said they hide it you
don't find out until much later if ever
what the sum of the sources
were it's it's so complex that as a
parent you're just
mystified and families break apart over
this issue I'm not exaggerating one
iota they do it wrecks families and the
hardest single thing to do when you
first encounter it is to get the person
Afflicted to admit they need
help that's all that's the single
hardest thing to even say Let's go see a
therapist and they deny it and you find
out that maybe there are other people in
their Circle who are obsessed with
weight or diet or something like that
and you find out it's not an isolated
thing and how do you get them to turn
the corner to
say maybe I do maybe I need to look at
this and one of the ways you can do it
is to find someone that they will agree
to just ask it's all you're asking
that's all you're
praying just
ask and if it means you how do you
convince them because they say say you
don't know what you're talking about if
you're a
parent and one of the ways it's only one
but why leave any Lo stone unturned in
this is that they can find a source that
says you can talk about this check in
this is a real
concern it's not
fake then maybe that's not what their
friend is telling them maybe that's not
what they're believe it or not their
friend mother who is obsessed about
weight is telling
them that's a real example I just gave
you so when one of your children's
Mother's friend's mother is advocating
it you got an uphill swim you really
do and so then you have to say how do I
get that how do I break this cycle how
do I help them break this cycle and one
way is having a source that sits there
and says we can talk about
this and once you get them to talk about
it you can get them to
therapy but not
before thank you Mr chairman yeah just
want to point out that in the the two
years since you had the showed us the ID
basically that's when the national
change in 988 went from a suicide line
to a suicide and crisis line um also
mental health emergencies which we know
are many times associated with all these
things that people call hotlines for um
I guess I want to reiterate what um
representative Lea said that it's really
nice maybe maybe representative Corell
it is nice to have a human voice answer
the phone and I just know one number
that does that all the
time
would you have a suggestion then since
it's more than just the suicide hotline
for what to call that number that would
get everybody who could make use of
it I think that the the number that it
says was is suicide and crisis line but
it if you have any line afterwards which
is any emergency gets you know a human
to person to direct your call so what
would happen then if somebody were
calling
for
[Music]
um uh eating disorder and they reached
988 what would what does 988 do on the
other end um I'm assuming and don't know
this but I that they have protocol for
triaging which what kind of what's your
like 911 what's your emergency yes 988
what are you calling about and here's
where it is because they know they're an
after hours
um uh number and so there's going to be
different things that people are going
to be calling them
for would it be possible to do a little
more looking into this and maybe bring
this bill back with maybe a different
solution that had somebody at the end
the whole time that because that's my
biggest concern is that there's not
going to be a person
when you finally
call um when you call to get some
help for
someone and Emergency Services show up
often times they're taken to the
hospital the next day they're
out and whether it's for substance abuse
or probably eating
disorder what kind of
followup is going to happen when you
call the eating disorder the national
helpl line here that we have how do you
get this followup and I can tell you
right now there is no
followup in the hospital in St Johnsbury
there's no followup at Cottage Hospital
in Woodsville there's no followup at
Dartmouth
Hitchcock so what's the deal here is
there going to be more followup with the
the helpline
you know it's just something I put
outon
Damon so I'll try to address that
and would first of all absolutely agree
with you that Medical Center care for
eating disorders is about physically
stabilizing the person if in fact they
are in a medical crisis like their
electrolytes might be really low they'll
have an IV and get their electrolytes
restored um but it's very shortterm
and it
is I would say almost
always especially in our small rural
hospitals but even Dartmouth Dartmouth
disbanded their eating disorder
treatment um
unit gosh I don't even know how long ago
25 years ago a long time
ago in most medical
centers it's emergency room triage
they're not even necessarily admitted
and they're not people who are expert in
the mental health aspects of Eating
Disorders they're expert at um helping
that people's person stay alive so that
they are physically restored a little
bit um it's a serious problem in the
field that needs a lot of education and
work my understanding is that the
alliance will
both provide local contact resources so
for example here we have the center for
eating
disorders um cedc which is in conquered
um their um initial site is in Cambridge
Mass but they've had a satellite
satellite site here for a long time very
capable caring trained
professionals that's largely where the
alliance would refer people cedc would
do an
evaluation um and then help that person
know what resources were available for
them locally in terms of therapy
dietitians knowledgeable medical
providers or if they were at a level of
risk that they needed a full day
treatment program or Residential Care to
help them access that CDC
does 3 six 3 hour 6 hour and I think
maybe they now have a longer hour per
day than that here in conqur but they
don't have Residential Care here vast
majority of people with eating disorders
don't need residential care as long as
they're they're diagnosed and treated
sooner um
so my understanding of the alliance
Services is they will make sure that
that person is connected
with human beings trained capable
Professionals in their
geography and or there is a lot of
access to care online since Co we have
really learned that you can actually do
very effective very helpful
care remotely and it's made access
to very experienced very capable field
people in the field much more accessible
because there's not enough people in
every zip code in the country or in New
Hampshire so one of those um approaches
I feel very confident that the ball will
not be dropped for a particular person
it's
not 15-year-old Jane Doe called the
alliance had a conversation and that was
the end of it they will follow
up further representative pel thank
you we certainly want to be on top of
helping people as quickly as
possible and I was very active in
finding the problems with the bot on the
um on the on the eating disorder hotline
last
year 15 days before the
current law requiring the National
Suicide Prevention Lifeline be put on
the cards the name has already changed
on that suicide Lifeline as
representative dry said it is now the um
suicide and crisis
Lifeline we've already gotten testimony
that well we've got received express
mail that the National Alliance for
eating disorders intends to to expand
their hours my concern is that at the
rate that we move in the legislature we
will not be able to keep up with helping
these people fast enough and I'm
wondering if there is a better way than
trying to trace this with legislation to
make sure that these people get the help
that they
need refes Cornell did you have your
hand up or I was just wondering if we
know that if they call 988 which triage
is they don't say
are you in crisis and if they say no I'm
looking for someone to talk to I have a
lot of questions they don't say this is
the number for the national eating
disorder um line um you should call them
tomorrow we don't know that you know so
if it's not a crisis and they call 988
we don't know that they don't revert if
they triage we don't know that they
don't revert them refer them to
something
else
represent
R yeah and in a Twist of irony if you
call after hours at the alliance they'll
say call 988 so I don't know if we're
going in a in a loop there or not i' I'd
hesitate to speak for them now because
really need to investigate that more
before I can make an answer but I do
know that they are you know when you
open it up to Mental Health crisis that
that runs the gamut and if you're a
trained dispatcher you know with
somebody's in crisis but you also know
if they're not in crisis but needing
help and this is really um I went
through helping pass out plantlets uh in
Sullivan County when the change came um
to allow people to know that there was a
change in services in 988 and that they
had expanded things and the desire there
is not to involve EMS police and
ambulances unless it's absolutely
necessary that people actually respond
better when there's different kinds of
coverage for an emergency like that and
that was part of the reason for for
changing this number um but I would
hesitate to speak for them unless I
really talk to them to to understand
that represent leus that's why I was
wondering if we could wait like till
next week to make a decision which would
give us time to actually call 988 and
ask them how they would deal with this
and so we have answers to that to try to
figure out what is the best thing to do
because we all want to help these kids
or
adults further representative
Tanner I don't want to be labor the
point but 998 went through some changes
too um
and what is the harm versus what is the
good that would come out of putting the
Eating Disorders number on that
card does it harm 988 does it does it
make a
that much of a I mean does it make some
sort of difference or does it give a
benefit to kids to parents perhaps um to
families um so I think in your own mind
if you just kind of weigh the risk
management kind of thing on this that
yes 988 is on there it's always going to
be on there they're not going to type
Eating Disorders over the top of 988 988
is a crisis and suicide number like I
said it it had its own problems a few
years ago as well as it went through
some changes and
funding we now have this Eating
Disorders number we now have more
information about the seating disorders
number what's the risk here the to save
a couple of lives so I urge you to vote
um against the itl thank
you further discussion representative
pel sorry
I'm the risk is that the line the name
of the line for the National Suicide
Prevention has changed now it includes
crisis so now we do not have that on the
back of the student ID cards so we are
missing a significant portion of the
population that could be receiving the
mental health care that they need
because in legislation law which moves
very very slowly we're already two years
behind we need to change the name on the
ID
cards we're going to lose people or
unintentionally harm the people people
we intend to help further discussion
represent cordel yes um the harm as I
see it is that if a student calls this
number and what what do they get a
record if it's not during the hours of
operation but you know are they put into
some kind of phone Loop and I I just
feel like that would be um harmful I
just had to say
that representative
Damon so if I'm hearing correct ly we
are having debate about will we harm
someone who calls and doesn't get a live
person and therefore we won't make this
communicated and readily available 12
hours a day to the people who would be
helped by the folks who are most expert
at this that makes no sense to me at all
I would also note representative dr's
good explanation relative to the 988
number that people respond better to
care that is not the sirens and the
ambulance unless it's a a crisis that
requires that this is the same concept
people respond better to the people who
know best how to help them and that's
what this
is rep
that can we no we Hammer this out can we
put an
amendment no we beyond amendments for
today well this would
be not just for to not for today right
the question is could we do this hotline
but also while we're at it
relabel the one that we already did
because that would not completely be
an uh a what is the word I want non-
gerain amendment that we could take this
opportunity to fix that 988 and put the
the okay we could do it here this isn't
an early
Bill represent Ford you the last one she
look like something say oh rep
cascaden you youve already spoken let
represent cascad you haven't drilled in
on this one yet go ahead then represent
Ford that'll be it you know what I'm
thinking in hindsight um I think the
idea of having the Eating Disorders
number on the student
card makes a statement whether the
number Works whether it's not in service
whatever but it says that we as a body
recognize this is a serious
problem and in listening to
representative dry I can see as I have
have seen other things happen this way
that because we're focusing on one issue
three four five years down the
road there's going to be a different
type of system and it may go to one
number that triages to whatever the
topic is but for
now if we don't OTP this bill and get
this on the books it means we're kicking
the can down the road and we need to
focus and let the public know our
constituents know that we recognize this
is
serious but I think down the road you're
going to see because we want kids to
access mental health we want them to
access help for eating disorders we
might want to have them access helped if
they've experienced childhood trauma or
if they're living in an abusive
situation so I can see that the system
for kids support will transition down
the road it's just not there yet but
that's what I'm envisioning to
happen representative
Ford thank and thank you Mr chair in the
same spirit I would encourage you not to
think of a
solution there is no one
solution it's a very broad problem and
the solution is not going to be any one
thing it's going to require us to
encourage people through one way or
another to include this in the health
curriculum in the schools get it out in
the in the public by through letters of
uh uh to the editor or whatever that
this is an issue which the culture must
address you see all the tv ads night
after night after night about how to be
skinny and how to over exercise how to
do all those things which someone seems
to think are desirable
some of those people look pretty weird
to me but
nonetheless I can't in truth I they look
strange but I'm call be that as it may
are they
healthy and so you look at kids get hit
with all of this stuff more than we do
they're the ones who walk around like
that they even have an ad that says when
the uncertain happens that the guy's
walking into traffic not looking where
he's going that that's not uncertain
that's dead certain it's going to happen
he's going to get hit by a car or a
truck or something and
so when the kids are exposed to all that
I think we need to expose the opposite
bring it out get it in the newspapers
get it in all the talk shows and all the
other wherever you have to go to get
it but get the word out and I would say
that let's don't think in terms of how
encourage us not to don't think in terms
of just a an approach or a particular
this is a start nothing more okay what
we're going to do is we're gonna have a
five minute carcass and then we're come
back and we're going to act on this
bill no we're going to have a five
minute caucus right now we all have
something we could like to you know
bring it up so let's get this thing
rolling
here we have a clerk that's got a to get
out of here
yeah
called
988 and I
said they come up as you know what kind
of almost what your emergency how can I
help you and I said here's the what
here's the deal we're trying to talk in
a committee about what to put on the
back of a of an ID and I want to know um
it it took me less than 30 seconds to
talk to a real human being and they had
a triage between was I a veteran or not
and then then it was she was right there
and I said what would you do if someone
called with it with a problem uh not not
a crisis not even suicide but just a
problem with an eating disorder and she
said um well for one thing I would see
what the moment is is this a crisis
moment where they where what's their
need right in the moment we talk through
the moment um I said okay um not
everyone feels like they're in a crisis
because of this do you have resources to
connect people do yes we have resources
to do that do you have resources to
counselors yes we have resources to
counselors um would it you know would it
throw you off it it wasn't eating the
disorder no not at all um what else did
they say she said what we feel is people
need to talk to human being and that's
what they capture in the moment when
they call they have a person who's a
counselor who's ready who's who answers
the phone to talk to them and their idea
there is then to sort out what is the
need of this person sometimes it might
be those mobile um mental health units
that come that are not that don't bring
lights and Sirens with them um sometimes
it might just be reference and research
and uh and referral and sometimes it
might be sitting there and spending the
time that that person needs to talk and
I think I covered every question that I
could think of um but they were very
amenable to my
questions thank
you okay is there any more discussion on
this bill we had some discussion whether
there should be an amendment put
forward repor
penell at the very
least this has brought our attention to
the fact that we need to change what's
on the back of the ID cards right now um
so I
would consider supporting this bill if
we put forth an amendment that would
also add changing what's currently back
on the back of the student ID card to
the
correct
organization Mr chair yes uh could that
Amendment be done in the
Senate we spent a lot of time we spent a
lot of time on this bill today yeah
amendments can be made in the Senate we
can do that in the Senate uh to address
that it's an option represent
Tanner um so the person calls 988 like
you said and they need somebody to talk
to and this person is let's say a fearly
experienced counselor probably received
counsel probably received training
on crisis management and suicide
prevention it's not hard to think that
in a conversation they could very well
say something that is considered a
trigger for an eating disorders person
it happens I've heard it happen with
EMTs picking up a litter and saying oh
wow this is so light and it's like the
last thing that they should have said to
that particular person because it was a
trigger for her eating disorder
so once again I just want to say I don't
think we need an amendment I think we
need to vote on this bill because we
need to to as representative Ford said
bring this issue to the
Forefront
provide something that's easy for kids
to see easy for parents to see that
changes every year their IDE cords
change every year so it isn't a really
big deal on that you know I think if you
want to vote against this vote against
it but it it's going to save lives if
you vote for this to put this on the ID
card so just remember
that representative
pno thank you um I hear what you're
saying representative Tanner and I hear
what you're saying representative Myer
um I just am concerned that we're
already not helping as many people as we
could because of the limited name on the
back of the current ID card and I also
have concerns with sending an amendment
over to the Senate because I'm pretty
sure I know what kind of a bill it would
be added to and I probably would have to
vote for something I might not want to
support in order to get this ID name
changed
okay this is not an early Bill we don't
have to really finish it out right now
at this very moment if there's an
amendment that's going to come forward
and deal with what some are concerned
about um that's an option for us repon
neon I would
like I would like us to postpone this
until tomorrow and I will bring forward
the requested amendment to update the
name so that hopefully we can
efficiently vote on this
tomorrow and I will trust that we are
all in this
together with that I think what we're
going to do is stop it right where we
are and if somebody can try to get
something we can deal with it tomorrow
because it's on the docket for tomorrow
as well and it can continue forward
represent pel did you have something oh
I just want to say that I want to make I
want to I want to write the amendment
you want to write an amendment would you
please do so y yeah and so we will come
back tomorrow this is we're done for
today and we will we'll you know come
forward and deal with this one tomorrow
good that'll give me a chance to find it
I don't know where I put the
sheet
me